oh you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
perfect hey what's up guys welcome back
to the dope as usual podcast my name is
thomas dopeziola this is marty o'neil
and this is the dopes usual podcast
we're here to talk about life problems
drugs accomplishments and everything in
between
i'm trying to and if you know me
personally know how [ __ ] hyped i am
right now i'm already knows everybody
knows guys today's guest is uh legendary
stevo thank you so much for being here
dude damn that was scary that's that was
scary [ __ ] [ __ ] dj horn oh you don't
hear it he's putting [ __ ] horns on
just imagine
oh good man so i before we i know we
were talking before i didn't want to say
it i uh i've been watching this jacket
since the sixth grade i watched the day
it came out how old do you know 32.
yeah i've been watching
it was like you got it right right when
it started i mean
before you can go out and do drugs with
your friends you sit at home go what's
coming on at eight simpsons so an mtv's
like nuke show this dude jumped a river
and broke his ankle this is the new [ __ ]
we're watching then right you know what
i'm saying it was crazy man like you
think that okay you were 12 when it came
out and like that's just like the
like the
ultimate like you know you grew up with
it you know
but it's so alarming
yeah and i'm not trying to toot my own
horn or anything but like
i feel
very much like uh matthew mcconaughey's
character in that movie
uh
dazed and confused oh he just says they
keep getting i get older and they just
stay the same age because dude like it
it's
it's it's uncomfortable the way that
like there's like now in 2021
there's 12 year olds that are like no
way i can't even believe it you know
like i don't even know what i attribute
that to i mean i suppose i like i've
been um
you know active i've kind of evolved
into like the youtube space and
everything like that like uh
so but i just don't quite understand how
such a young
demographic is still like you know
coming on board i know you're that you
are in jackass so you don't see it you
gotta remember
you guys are still the coolest
[ __ ] out man no matter what you
guys are the group that everybody wants
to [ __ ] hang out with for the rest of
their lives no matter what everybody
goes man forever man i know you're
sitting here but you guys already know
i'm [ __ ] excited i've been a fan i've
watched every single thing you guys have
ever done i watched every cky i got them
all been just hyped i know you guys
weren't cky but
yeah yeah yeah
i was never i had zero appearances yeah
no it was it was done before you guys
even started but
that's our group you know what i'm
saying uh sure the skater kids all my
friends are skaters then this came out
and like shopping cart [ __ ] did it once
go i'm out
i'm too [ __ ] fat to be falling like
that guys and that was it man but we had
our we had our years of it um i remember
i was telling marty in sixth grade i got
the first jackass shirt you guys dropped
with all of you on the front
oh yeah i don't even remember jack i
shared with all of us on the front yeah
i had it it was uh i think there was a
flag on it too ah okay yeah but i
remember the skull and crossbones i said
jackass and i got a sixth grade
i walked in i remember
i remember taking the picture with the
flag oh well that was the shirt still
awake
you know
on like day two or three of a cocaine
bender
and it was like the last thing we did
was shot that photo and then we had to
go like to the airport or something yeah
dude i remember uh
i watched watch the show and you
remember as a kid you watch something
the next day you come back and
everybody's like did you see what the
[ __ ] happened last night on tv because
it wasn't there was no internet it's pre
pre-internet there there was internet
but it but but videos were really not
playing on the internet yeah no like
ebom's world and rotten.com were like
the only things you could see crazy [ __ ]
but i remember coming back to school and
that was it man yeah i remember the
first time i saw audio video inputs on a
computer i was like what
like damn that you know
because for me
like growing up like trying to come up
and and and get attention
meant
like plugging two vcrs together like
recording on these vhs cassette tapes
and like playing play on one and record
on the other and i would do that like to
like that was my process of editing then
once i had the edited tape i put that in
the
original one hit play and record and i
would just do that and duplicate these
tapes
then physically walk with these cassette
tapes to the post office
and mail them like to like anybody who i
thought would watch them and like it's
such a different world system to be able
to upload some [ __ ]
oh yes one two buttons and you get a
mass text a mass post and it's such a
fascinating question to to ponder like
had i been born
20 years later and like be coming up in
like you know
and what you came up in with with you
would i have
been able to to pull it off you know
like in in a different landscape and
without sounding like uh you know a
pompous douchebag i genuinely believe
that i'm such a tireless and just
persistent attention [ __ ]
that i would have pulled it off like no
matter no matter what time i don't think
that's what you're going to say i
thought you're going to say my work out
there would it persevere same thing yeah
i mean i'm just like i'm a tireless
[ __ ] attention [ __ ]
and and that that that's by the way my
title for like just you know somebody's
going to ask me it's like well you've
you've written a book you've been in you
know movies you do stand-up comedy like
you're it's a good title you know like
like i've done so many different things
in sort of the field of uh media or
whatever in the the general world of
media
that like it's you know it's a
legitimate question like do we call you
a stuntman do we call you an actor do we
call you a comedian like do we call you
an author and i'm like dude
straight up that's all i am is an
attention [ __ ] like every like like
regardless of what i've done i could
save
within probably like a
less than a percentile
margin of error a hundred percent of the
decisions i make are based on attention
seeking you know like or at least any
major decisions but that's your business
though it's different right and and now
like here's the the crazier thing
is that like while i say that as you
know uh
somewhat
self-deprecating like i'm taking a jab
at myself be like oh yeah i'm an
attention [ __ ] like it's not a
flattering
title to give oneself however
i really think that you could take a a
very very like just big picture look at
how the world operates
and arrive at the conclusion that
the attention of human beings is the
single most valuable commodity known to
me exactly it truly is i mean if you
look at like super bowl commercials and
how much like it costs like this how
much of the world's economy is driven by
advertising revenue will tell you that
attention is
you know i've been running up the views
forever like right right so so like
that's my deal i don't know what even
got me on that it's [ __ ] like it's
important to acknowledge that the value
is what they paid the millions of
dollars for for sure and the views in
that attention that you figured out how
to do as a young boy basically just
doing crazy [ __ ] nobody's even now i
feel like nobody's really been in your
lane no nobody's like uh you see people
pop up and go oh you're doing stevo [ __ ]
but now it's cool with a person with a
personality that's for everyone like
it's yeah i i i think that that that's
you know complimentary i'm flattered and
i'm grateful
but i think i think there's plenty of
people
you know particularly now like like
here's something interesting which is
that
it's true that when jackass came out
still the video camera was not yet a
household item you know like it like i
mean sure a lot of people had them but i
remember when i started making videos
and i was uh 15 years old
in 1990 when i made my first video and
it was just like shitty skateboarding
but at that time
there were only enough home video
cameras like just in the general like
publix possession
to generate content for like one tv show
which was called america's funniest home
videos i think they still have that show
to this day of course
and that was just like you know like
like if there was footage then
that's that show was that was just got
by on how many cameras there were then
gradually like say through like you know
through the 1990s
then you know clearly more people
started acquiring video cameras but
still i wouldn't consider it had to be
well off for like a dab oh yeah right
it was it was a luxury item yeah and um
still there there weren't enough people
who had video cameras i don't think to
consider it a common household item but
there but increasingly more people got
video cameras so we saw more tv shows
pop up which were based on home video
camera footage and not necessarily
comedy like america's funniest home
videos it was like a family-friendly
friendly comedy show but then we saw
other shows like real tv yes supposed to
say yeah which by the way was my first
tv show that i was ever on no [ __ ] i
watched that every week it was it was it
was pretty gnarly man what would you do
how did you get that if you hadn't
mentioned it jesus christ oh that's the
first thing i was like real tv was like
you know like caught on tape yeah yeah
and they had these um
these commercials which said uh you know
real tv and and i guess that was the
commercial that promoted the actual you
know episodes airing and also or maybe
it was on the show itself but if you
have any footage that you think we
should see
call this number and contact us
and uh and and and well it was the very
beginning of 1999
and and i called up the number on the
screen and and then just left a
voicemail voicemail
saying
um my name is you know i probably called
myself stevo because i had been stevo
since like 93
and uh you know but i'm stephen glover
aka stevo and i i
it's not that i have footage that you
might want to see
like i
actually have footage that you need
badly you're [ __ ] hurting for it you
know
you're [ __ ] hurting for it and um
and and i i put together a real i'm like
the the
best
quality because my [ __ ] was like
like uh
just
degraded from being taped from back and
forth
oh i can't imagine that there's so many
like
you know
so many generations of recording uh down
like
you know downgrading but but whatever i
had that was like really like reasonably
good quality of of uh resolution
and uh like you know quality of content
i put it all together on one video tape
and i sent it to them and sure enough
man they they called me back
and they said that they wanted um
that they were very interested in
acquiring the footage of me
setting myself on fire on top of the
roof of
the three-story apartment building
and then
doing the simultaneous fire breathing
front flip off the roof of the of the
building where i landed in five feet of
water and and i'm six feet five feet of
water
and my reaction my reaction was like
i was like
out of all the [ __ ] that i [ __ ] sent
you that's that's all you want are you
[ __ ] kidding me like you like
that's it you want that and and you know
i mean i was like of course being like
uh it's kind of kind of cocky about it
man i was talking to somebody on the
phone i said yeah no that that's the one
we like that's what we want and here's
what we want to give you
five hundred dollars
for
exclusive rights to your footage oh my
god now it's like i've never heard the
tear the term exclusive rights like what
does that mean they're like well that
means that uh that we would own it from
that point and we would all we would be
the only ones who own it you know like
you don't own it anymore
and and that just sounded [ __ ] awful
to me you know i remember thinking like
oh you didn't want to do that well i
mean give it away and then what i can't
do anything with it ever again yeah
that's 500 bucks
that's your first deal probably 500 is a
lot if you're young and like broken [ __ ]
well i mean
like even at that time
i had like
you know i had [ __ ] ambitions i never
thought that it would be like that i
would be a household name or anything
but but i really [ __ ] was trying to
work towards some kind of something that
i could call a career
and that to strip me of the rights to
that footage would really be like
that that footage could no longer work
for me to get me to wherever my my goal
was
i get it and so i remember like hanging
out but i was just like oh man i i don't
know like i'll get back to you or
whatever and i called it my dad who's
you know
like uh
that people generally know that my dad
was a wildly successful corporate
executive and i called him up and i was
like dad dad dad and i explained the
situation and dad said
hey
like calm down man you know like like
calm down it's not [ __ ] complicated
take a deep breath you know ask yourself
like uh like at which point is it a deal
breaker
and draw a line in the sand and stick to
it he says from what i'm hearing you
tell me
it sounds like
exclusivity is a deal breaker so why
don't you go back to them and say
hey i'm not comfortable with giving up
exclusive rights i'll i'll give you the
i'll give you non-exclusive rights which
means that you can include it on your tv
show but i can i still own it every bit
the same way that i did and i can
continue to exploit it you know forever
and uh i'll give you non-exclusive
rights and but you have to give me a
thousand bucks for that oh
you came back and goes how about this
give me more and [ __ ] you yeah yeah yeah
did it work
i totally got it i got a thousand bucks
and uh and i was on the tv show and i
continued to to own the footage and
what's crazy about that too
is that uh
that was the
the first
um
the first contract that i ever had which
was uh like a legitimate like
entertainment within like the
entertainment world and and my dad like
helped me with that you know
and it was that's so significant
because
i
had dropped out of college in 1993.
i told everybody i'm gonna [ __ ]
they're like what are you gonna do now
you just got kicked out of the dorms
[ __ ]
for smashing i smash out the window on
the [ __ ] 12th floor balcony and
[ __ ] climbed through over onto the
roof and then i'm climbing up a radio
tower on the roof of a twelve street
you're doing crazy reckless [ __ ] without
people filming you just on your free
time yeah one of my earliest [ __ ]
clips from from back then
was uh on that same 12th floor balcony
and i'm hanging off the railings by my
bare hand like over time i've seen that
[ __ ] i know what you're talking about
yeah like uh
i was going for it man and um
so these they saw me up on
on this radio tower they called the cops
and i'm still up there i'm all [ __ ]
drunk and pounding booze and and the
cops come onto the roof and they're like
you know so i got kicked out of the
dorms i was already failing classes and
then i upped and just [ __ ] took off
and and and dropped out so
like as i'm like getting ready to
physically leave the camps i'm dropping
out like i'm loading up a van with this
[ __ ] kid and we're gonna drive from
where we were this was at the university
of miami we're going to drive to
northern california to go get try and
get jobs at [ __ ] valley ski resort in
lake tahoe so random yeah like uh
because that's how i'm going to become a
crazy stomach people are like
like what are you gonna [ __ ] do now
you know like you [ __ ] blew it and i
was like oh dude i've got like
i'm gonna [ __ ] become a crazy famous
stunt man by by videotaping myself doing
[ __ ] stunts with a home video camera
and that took and like literally every
[ __ ] single person that i
that i expressed this plan to
legitimately felt sorry for me because
there was no [ __ ] precedent for that
you know we're talking about even a lane
that didn't exist
not [ __ ] exist if you were going to
be a stunt man like okay maybe that
would be a viable career but for
god's sakes you don't [ __ ] you're not
going to pull it off with a home video
camera you know like there was no i was
100
talking about forging like my own
lane which had never existed people felt
sorry for me and and like honestly like
it didn't go well man like i was
homeless for
for the next three years after that oh
[ __ ] yeah like bouncing i mean you stay
homeless
i was a couch surfer
and uh you know and and whatever it was
like after three years of being homeless
then uh i found out about the the clown
college the ringling brothers and barnum
billy clown college and i remember
thinking well [ __ ] if i can get into
clown college for ringling brothers and
barnum and bailey circus
then
all of a sudden i'll be a bona fide
trained circus professional take you
serious and people take it more
seriously so i'm the only [ __ ] in
history i ever went to clown college to
be taken serious
you're on some eight mile [ __ ] him
stunt man
and uh and so
the the the point of all this is that
when i
my successful corporate executive
businessman father like
you know when i dropped out of college i
didn't even like wasn't even in contact
with him he didn't know what the [ __ ]
was going on with me and our
relationship was like not
really good because like i wasn't doing
[ __ ] anything that he was stoked on
you know and like
and and and then even when i went to
clown college my dad was not [ __ ]
back and that when i was dropping out of
college and saying i'm gonna become a
stunt man the the little contact that i
had with my dad
was that he went to the like local
library and did like a bunch of research
on like the the like you know
new advances in uh like a cgi technology
and he came back and said hey you're
talking about being a stunt man but like
i'm doing all this research which
indicates that
the job of stuntman is going to be made
completely obsolete because they're just
doing they're just creating these uh
these effects so like you're going in
and i was like oh okay yeah dad whatever
like what i'm gonna do is find like a
crew of [ __ ] crazy dudes and we're
gonna [ __ ] cruise around and we're
gonna do stuff elephant [ __ ] yeah right
and i just wasn't here you know somebody
so the point is that my
like my like whole plan
was was something that really like
dad
dad did everything he could to try to
talk me out of it he did everything he
could to
to like
resist it to just [ __ ] on it you know
and like and when i went to clown
college dad wasn't backing that either
and uh you know that like so from like
1993
i went to clown college in uh 97
and then it was in 1998.
like all those years my dad and i our
relationship was strange as [ __ ] strange
as [ __ ] we were like i was not doing
well i was [ __ ] homeless i was i was
straight to hurt and struggling is that
why i had what i mean yeah i've been
like i'm saying financially i just
was like financially like i had enough
pride that i that i didn't really i
didn't ask i'd rather sleep on the
[ __ ] streets just say dad you know i
need money you know what is clown
college like like what's the death
college life there was there was like
where you can't do a flip side where is
it like it was in florida they ended up
like they can't like ending it but but
uh yeah dad wasn't backing it our
relationship hadn't been that great and
then in 1998 dad took it on himself
to like he waited until we were in
person and he said he said hey
like along the lines like i want to
acknowledge that like that my uh
that i i he says i think that i have
done a disservice to you
by not supporting you in this career
path that you're clearly
like like dedicated to he says and and
and frankly i chose a career path that
my father
like wasn't super thrilled about either
and my dad said the same thing to me he
said you're not doing what i
would have chosen for you to do
but since you're clearly committed to
what you're doing i just want to pledge
my support to you and and uh and for you
to be
like as good as you can be at it were
you successful i have not made a [ __ ]
penny too
that's what's so that's what's such a
great question and and it's so
like just kind of gives me goosebumps to
this day because i think a lot of people
who
who
do achieve like great success in uh in
entertainment
like and and then like
they got a bunch of people jumping on
the bandwagon you know and and i i it
really comes down to the fact that i i
mean i had had a little bit of a couple
photos and skateboard magazines that i
had not been paid to
you know
i didn't get paid [ __ ] for anything were
you a legit skater i was a religious
skater but i was i wasn't that great and
when i was featured in skateboard
magazines there was never a picture of
me skateboarding it was like oh this
[ __ ] lighting himself
you know like this guy jumping off this
building like it's just tight though man
i was stoked hell yeah i i was stoked
but uh
yeah i had nothing to [ __ ] brag i had
not got i had not made any money
i had not achieved anything and then dad
said
i i pledge to support you and and then
like it was like after that conversation
and then like with the real tv thing and
i'm like and i'm like dad nice i can
pull into myself motivation man
so then so before i got anywhere
like i got like dad was was was backing
me dad was supporting me and like that
very first deal
ever that i ever got and dad worked it
out with me and so like
it's such a a
something i'm so profoundly grateful for
it's such a massive point for me to make
that
that the the wonderful relationship i
have with my father today
is not
it's not that i have a great
relationship with my dad because i'm
successful
rather
i'm successful because i have a great
relationship with my dad and that's good
man i like that that's really cool
[ __ ] huge yes i [ __ ] love that
actually that's a [ __ ] huge yes man
and uh and yeah dude it's killer man not
a lot of performers can say that
right i experienced that yeah and it's
so funny too because like my dad's like
a human calculator you know he's just
like straight like logically you know
like
and and there's been so many things over
the years that dad's just like it's not
he doesn't [ __ ] get it alligators
like alligators
yeah like
you know and and to extend like he'll be
like a little worried you know like like
son how can it be safe for you to swim
with sharks when you've got meat
strapped all over you you know i'm like
um i write watch something your dad
is a straight corporate man right pepsi
in brazil yeah he was the president of
pepsico in all of brazil when i was six
months old wow so that's why there we
lived in i was born in england yes we
moved to
brazil when i was six months old
and i spoke my first words in portuguese
because
um
i was i saw very little of my parents as
a baby
they had live-in maids
oh so you've got and it was the living
the living maids were the only people
who spent any meaningful time with me
which is why one of my first words came
out i had learned i said spoken
portuguese because i was learning
yeah from the maids so
your parents are straight up like richie
rich style the movie uh i mean i guess
like uh i'm saying in terms of they're
not really there
oh yeah i suppose yeah and even if they
were there like like i mean okay so i
mean i learned to speak in in brazil
born in england and and mind you my mom
was born in canada
and my dad was born in america
so my mom being canadian makes me a
canadian my dad being american makes me
american me being born in england makes
me british so i have three valid
passports i'm tripping no [ __ ] yeah i've
never heard of that i didn't know that
that's how it worked yeah i'm i'm
it's called triple national i'm i'm
legitimately a citizen of three
different countries and i have valid
passports for each of each other awesome
the other thing is that i spoke my first
words in portuguese and i went on to
speak fluent portuguese today do you
still speak it no but but it's in there
man when i was in summer school or no
sorry when i was in summer camp
uh in uh
like when i was 11 years old
like there was some kids from not brazil
but they're from portugal and both
countries speak portuguese
and uh and they were like dude [ __ ]
in your sleep last night you're speaking
[ __ ] before oh [ __ ]
i spoke three languages fluently by the
age of three what the [ __ ] and forgot
two of them completely by the age of
five
i used to be spanish i was a kid so i
get it yeah i don't speak spanish now so
it's because when i was two years old we
moved from brazil to venezuela and i
spoke fluent spanish in nursery school
and i was speaking english so i spoke
portuguese spanish and
and english and then like by the time i
was five i just didn't use english for
portuguese anymore so that just went
away but in one sense you think okay so
you learn three languages and then you
forgot two of them you stupid [ __ ]
fuck-face dumbass you know what
it was because if anybody had been
mindful to keep me speaking those
languages then i would it would be a
very useful tool for me to have to be
able to speak three different languages
to be bilingual let's learn bilingual
but trilingual
would be [ __ ] epic uh and i lost
those languages which is a shame but i
on the other hand it's uh it's like i
believe like a scientific [ __ ] fact
that when babies
learn multiple languages
that just by the virtue of learning
multiple languages at such a young age
when your brain is developing that like
that you end up using more of your brain
i could see that being true so while i'm
a [ __ ] loser for forgetting two
languages like i came out on top i think
for learning them in the first place i
think that that developed my brain and
and some like for sure it doesn't play
mozart when people are pregnant just
opening up brains i think yeah
especially having to go yes oh yeah
that's just one language for a kid
that's a smart [ __ ] kid
i mean
here's the other thing it's [ __ ] easy
for babies to learn two languages you
know like if you wait until you're an
adult to learn like additional languages
it's harder than [ __ ] but for but for
babies it's just like you know babies
toddlers whatever like when you're like
when you're
you're so malleable you're like a sponge
you just soak everything up and so i
learned those languages easier than [ __ ]
and i think that that probably speaks to
why it's beneficial to learn languages
when you're so young because uh
you know you're taking advantage of this
ability to learn which is you know
that's true and your brain's not full of
all of growing up [ __ ] in your brain you
know what i'm saying i feel it's like
the core memories that you remember yeah
and i think too that that just like uh
because because when you're a baby you
don't have like like the necessity of
learning to learning the language is
like
you know you don't have any other way to
do it dude like i think that that like
there's something to it it's like here's
a controversial position which i've said
before and people have been like yo you
got to edit that out you know
go for that i don't give a [ __ ] you
don't have to edit this out leave that
[ __ ] in
this is my position is that
like
if you want to
go fishing
and catch a fish as i understand it you
have to get a license
to catch a [ __ ] fish yeah like the
things that you have to get a license to
do are like pretty
you know
yeah however
any [ __ ] [ __ ]
can become a parent can be and you don't
have to get a license no qualifications
you don't have any qualifications you
can you can create a human being for
society to deal with right and i think
i think that's [ __ ] up it is it is i
think that like i mean i don't know what
i don't know that there's any kind of uh
of a really practical or or reasonable
solution to the issue unless you know
unless you are going to like
like like when a baby gets
uh circumcised you give them a vasectomy
at the same time the only way right and
then put them back together later on in
life yeah and and i don't know why like
the the whoa
that'd be crazy the whole um idea of of
you going to get a vasectomy and then a
vasectomy reversal
is uh is absolutely silly i heard i got
a vasectomy oh no [ __ ] yeah i don't want
what age i got it like in 2018. oh so
you're set on uh kid's not for me yeah i
got i found my girl and [ __ ] you know
we're engaged we don't want to [ __ ]
have kids and and so yeah so i went
ahead and did it now i learned like a
fair amount about like the vasectomy
deal
and um
what a vasectomy does is you've got your
balls where the sperm are are like
created you know generated
and um
there's a tube
connected to each ball
i caught him
vas deferens
vast deference and and so
the the the vast deference delivers the
sperm from your balls to your wiener and
then that's like uh where the blast
comes out i'm about to go through this
pretty sure dude against this [ __ ] right
now it's epic just go you already have
enough right do it
so i sure got enough
so the the the guy i think i forget what
my question was my vasectomy
the doctor told me so that's just silly
because
because even though like now all the
vasectomy means is that they're they're
uh cutting the vas deferens which is
that tube
they're disrupting the delivery of the
sperm to the wiener so that it just
can't come out
and and uh nothing that they're doing
and cutting that tube uh
like
stops the sperm from being made in the
in the balls
so
while it's not like uh particularly
painless i gather
like what you can do if you decide to
have children after getting vasectomy is
have
sperm extracted
from the balls which as i understand it
would mean that they've got to literally
stick a needle into your bowl and then
like extract sperm that way
and that doesn't sound very comfortable
at all it sounds like some [ __ ] you
would be doing on a video
[Laughter]
yo don't say that [ __ ] out loud
it does it does and i gotta i gotta
believe that you could be put under for
that procedure you have to be but but
what i'm getting to
is that i think that the people men and
women both parents
should have to get a [ __ ] license to
become parents i really believe strongly
in that and it's not even a bad idea and
i think that like that uh
that one of the
like
one of the requirements to get that
license should be
uh you know
taking a legit college-level course in
developmental
which is like one of the few college
courses that not i didn't just make it
through but i got like an a you know
that's right yeah i was fascinated by it
i was fascinated by it and like i
remember this from all the way back in
the 90s
but in this in this psychology course
there was uh they talked about uh
this this uh
[ __ ] scientist or whatever this
psychologist and this guy's his name is
i think he's a french guy his name was
piaget and he he came up with
piaget's uh theories of developmental
psychology and what was so [ __ ]
fascinating about it was that
he
he his his research indicated that the
very first
experiences that a human being has
like right out of the womb you know
other like very first [ __ ]
experiences are the ones which have the
most profound
lasting
impact on
that so so what happens
to a [ __ ] baby will determine for the
rest of that [ __ ] baby's life what
type of a person that is and he and he
narrowed it down to like
very specific things like uh like when
the baby just comes home from the
hospital if the baby is
is when the baby's quite it's gonna
happen the baby's gonna cry and it's
crib and like how you handle the baby
crying in the crib it it speaks volumes
about how this baby's gonna develop like
it for example if the baby's crying and
it's because the baby's just scared it
doesn't [ __ ] know what's going on
it's it's crying and like whatever
happens right there
is this is its first its first view the
first thing it learns about the whole
world you know and it's like and i know
that my dad even made a point as a point
of pride he says i'm not going to go in
there and [ __ ] reward him for crying
and it's going to give him a message
that if he [ __ ] cries he gets your
sister [ __ ] he can [ __ ] sit there
and [ __ ]
cry cry away because i'm going to
[ __ ] teach you how much that how far
that's gonna get you crying doesn't get
you anything that was my dad's he didn't
know
but but when you don't come to comfort
the baby while it's crying in the crib
then the very first thing that the baby
the very first impression the very first
idea of the whole world is i'm crying
i'm not okay
i'm scared i'm sad and the world it
[ __ ] is not
like the world's not not doesn't [ __ ]
care about me i need [ __ ] help and
and
this world this world i'm in and then
that like it's it's like uh
like like insecurity like uh you know
there's like [ __ ] the world you know
[ __ ] this world this world doesn't
[ __ ] care about me i don't [ __ ]
care about this world they just like
there's like deviants you know like you
know i'm a deviant [ __ ] probably
because of that you know
and then like there's another thing and
i was again i was so fascinated by this
when i took that college course they
said uh
when it comes to potty training you know
like like like there's no way around it
the baby's going to [ __ ] [ __ ] in its
diapers you know like it's like that's
there's it's completely natural right
and like a lot of parents taking i think
my dad too like take the position of
like oh we're gonna you know it's like
if the dog shits and you roll up
you don't do it there you know like if
if if potty training is something that
you take like a disciplinarian approach
to it like no that's wrong you know like
you don't don't do that
then like
then the baby gets this the the the what
the baby takes from that it's like
i didn't [ __ ] do anything wrong i
can't help that i just [ __ ] took a
[ __ ] you know
and i've just been scolded i've been
punished
for for doing something that was
absolutely not in my control i'm [ __ ]
not dead so so the the takeaway from
there is like even if i even if i do
like the right thing
even if like like no matter what i did
like
i'm wrong i've been told that i'm wrong
when i didn't do anything wrong so this
the world's not fair that is real though
i could totally see how you can ingrain
that into a kid like no matter what i
did i'm [ __ ] done i'm dumb yeah
that's the world's not [ __ ] fair you
know and then it's like
it goes it goes on and on i can't
remember them all but it just all made
so much [ __ ] sense i just thought to
myself from way back then in the 1990s i
just thought
[ __ ] man how can people be allowed to
have kids and not know these things you
know like
not know like this is [ __ ] super
important like my dad was deliberate
about doing the exact [ __ ] wrong
thing you know like
and and and we're they [ __ ] up they're
[ __ ] up kids man like i i don't want
to have kids but i but i think that's
because i have like a real respect for
what it means to have a kid to create a
human being how old was your dad when he
had you 30 oh she's a [ __ ] adult yeah
yeah most kids are out 15 16 and that's
i don't know about most kids oh where
i'm from your parents where i'm from uh
it's the in america it's the number one
spot for teenage pregnancy oh yeah
where's that uh merced by fresno up
north
yeah i did shows at the the university
of merced get the [ __ ] out of here yeah
seriously i double build a show at the
university of merced with rob schneider
get the [ __ ] i'm not there when was
this how long oh damn that was back in
uh 2012 i want to say i was there how
the [ __ ] did i know
well the only fun thing in town besides
drugs happens and i didn't know about
the [ __ ] it was it was good dudes
college games have always been a good
[ __ ] deal like you show up and just
wipe out their student council allotted
entertainment
yo i was there
i was there for the groundbreaking of
that that was our field trip for the
year in sixth grade we went across the
town to watch a guy dig a hole [ __ ]
whack
let me [ __ ] promote some [ __ ] dude
like uh you know i can't tell my my
story's like you know um
dude i've got a gnarly rad story in my
book
uh yeah i came out with a memoir what's
it called it's called professional idiot
[ __ ] i love it stevo a professional
idiot a memoir and um
it's uh it was new york times bestseller
it's the you know it's got the average
rating on amazon five stars it's the
best [ __ ] thing i've ever made
and uh it's just juicy it's juicier than
[ __ ] and um and on the ones on my
website
everyone's hand signed so you can get
like an autographed hand signed and
that's stevo.com
2011 and just two days ago delivered my
second book to the publisher do you know
what this is going to be called yet that
one um i i'm reluctant to uh to say the
title publicly because i wouldn't want
like if we don't have the the rights to
it secured
i wouldn't want anyone to snatch it and
then of course but um
but yeah dude like it might so my new
book
and i told you this before uh we sat
down man like
the the the original manuscript for my
first book uh you know i i gave it to
johnny knoxville i remember him uh
getting back to me said hey i'm like i
was impressed by your book it says just
my one note like as a friend
i i don't know if you should include
that story
that [ __ ] story
with uh you know from from when we did
that terry richardson photo shoot you
know
where uh
normal note you get when putting out a
book yeah take out the bukkakee yeah he
said he said i don't know i don't know
if the future misses oh
like if that's something that like uh
looking out for you yeah all right and i
was like i was like knoxville i
appreciate your concern but the cocky
story stays
and it's in there you know it's in there
along with all the rest of the [ __ ] up
sex and drugs and everything
but uh but
this is crazy because um
this time around you know and it's been
you know there's 10 10 years in between
books here and um
like
my new book
is uh i i honestly was so nervous about
the new book living up to how good the
first book was
and um just at some point in the process
while while i was you know
doing all the
revision and rewriting i was just like
dude
because i had concerns like my first
pass through it you know i i had
concerns i was like [ __ ] man and then
all those concerns we addressed them and
as i came through that last
pass of revisions and rewrites like i
was just like dude
we we're smashing that first book you
know we're every bit as gnarly
as you know and and like it's just
in a sense i delivered the manuscript to
the publisher two days ago as we sit
here and record this now
and um
this time
like i was super [ __ ] nervous about
sharing that original manuscript with
knoxville because like
because like i let it [ __ ] rip man
you know and like
like i i was like i have to share with
him because i think if he's gonna be
like offended
or like uh you know just like really
like have a problem with the like the
like how how candid i was and sharing
like like problems that we've had
between us and you know like
like open it like like i would like let
him let that
problem surface before it's before you
probably should you know
and i was just like i printed it i
printed it out and got a bound copy and
i'm dropping it in the envelope to send
it to him
and i was like oh so nervous and like
you know i overnighted it to him two
days ago so he received it yesterday
and then today i got a call from him
and and uh i just like i'm in the middle
of doing something and i see like oh
knoxville is calling me and i'm like
just my heart sinks and i'm like
like
i'm just i i pick up the phone and i'm
just ready for like how dare you
you know
how dare you and he says
um and this this call was today so i'm
like this is just so crazy like i've
never like obviously i've never been
able to share this with anybody it just
[ __ ] happened today he says i started
reading your book at 9 00 a.m this
morning and i just finished it and this
call came in at like
one something in the afternoon he read
it in one sitting and it's not like
you know
in like microsoft word pages which are
way bigger than a book page it was like
162 pages you know like
uh he read it in one sitting and i'm
just like okay here it comes and he's
like
he's like dude i
i i just have to tell you i'm so proud
of you i'm like wait nice like i'm just
and he's like dude like i just he told
me that he admired the rigorous honesty
like
how uh
self-aware i was
and i was like dude knoxville i was
ready for you to say how dare you he
said i didn't have any how dare you
moments he says what i had a lot of was
oh my god why is he saying this this
sounds really [ __ ] bad
but then when i when
whenever i thought that the next line
acknowledged how bad it sounded and
and that was like yeah accountability of
it and it's just like
it was just like
as i share this with you now like still
like all over my body i
i have like a physical sensation of
gratitude
you know like it's almost like my arms
are tingling like
like
yeah
like that there's there's relief there's
like there's gratitude and it's like
even and i was and i told him i told him
on the phone i said knoxville i was like
i can't tell you how much that means to
me because
like i was just really really sensitive
about like
how
personal it got about like uh you know
the things involving involving you you
know and there was no way on earth that
uh i that i wanted
you to not
see it first and then and he said he
just said that
you know it meant a lot to him that that
i was sensitive to that and that the way
that it was handled
you know as unflattering as it was but
it was just handled with such like
you know
self-awareness and honesty and it's just
like
maturity dude
he said like just that like
it it comes through so much like how
much work you've done on yourself and
how much growth it's been it's just like
dude
i mean i i already like knoxville is
just i call him the captain you know
like i feel like he's uh like a big
brother figure to me like the big
brother that you just like look up to so
much who's whose opinion matters so much
and uh and then like our director jeff
tremaine he's like a father figure for
me
the whole time right yeah yeah
the big brother guy right same same
everything jeff tremaine and it's like
these guys and then there's spike jones
who's like you know nice now
i think he is but uh but but those like
those are the guys who started the
company which which created those are
all the three creators of jackass is
knoxville tremaine and spike and like
they're like the powers that be
like as it relates to jackass you know
like they they call the shots and like
from a creative perspective
where
um
like
certainly they don't always agree on
everything creatively you know i think
they'll know they'll butt heads over
when they're wanting things to be
one way or the other
um on an individual level i would like i
don't think uh the any of them are
always right about any about anything
obviously because they don't always
agree but what i believe there's a like
1 000
track record for is that when they
arrive at a a consensus decision between
all three of them they always get it
right so like whatever
whatever creative call the three of
those guys make is like i just
i blindly trust that it's the right
[ __ ] call at this point man they've
never got it it's a winning formula
every [ __ ] time yeah it's not just my
opinion like everything that they've put
out the three of them has has been the
number one in whatever field it was
released you know like box office made
every single movie they've put they've
judged number one at the box office and
and i got to tell you that jackass
forever
which now is coming out in february
is so [ __ ] good man it's unbelievably
[ __ ]
like like jackass forever smashes the
[ __ ] out of the last jackass movie
jackass 3d
really smashes the [ __ ] out of it now
i'll i'll be candid that i don't think
that there's
ever going to be any such thing as
beating jackass number two jackass 2 was
just the waste time i've ever thrown up
before in public
the sweat suit cocktail [ __ ] that was
jack has three oh that was three that's
when i threw up in public
it wasn't billiard balls i think it was
like tennis ball or something it was
something [ __ ] up because that's the
only like i said we started doing all
the shits kids i lasted one round and
i'm out yeah that's just not fun yeah it
[ __ ] hurts
it's an early game i don't think
anything will ever be number two because
we were just so [ __ ]
gnarly reckless on that one you know
like we were all still super [ __ ]
like reckless like with with all the
drugs with the alcohol with the [ __ ]
everything dude with the the stunts like
like the risks that were that were being
taken
were like [ __ ] [ __ ] up and there
was just like a guardian angel looking
over us man you know like like on some
serious level i think that there's just
been like a major
like
like a network of guardian angels
and of course
and dude like heavy risks got [ __ ]
taken on the new one too knoxville like
on jackass number two he gets
blindfolded in front of a yak which is
like a super [ __ ] charged pissed off
bowl with like really long horns and
he's like blindfolded and he goes and
lights his cigarette and then the the
yak just straight scoops him and he does
like a complete revolution it was like
he just did a standing [ __ ] front
flip because the the yak scooped him
like that and in that full front flip
that he did
he landed on his feet and he got up and
walked away and was fine on the new
jackass movie
a bull
like charges him and and scoops him from
behind
so he said like he likes from behind and
pushes him forward so his head's coming
back and he did a flip and a half
so if he did a full flip he would have
gone back to his feet like he did in
jackass number two but he did a flip and
a half to his head
and so he had a concussion he had a
[ __ ] brain hemorrhage
oh he had this new one he had a brain
bleed and a concussion of course and a
broken wrist and a broken rib
[ __ ] like we're just straight and
considerably more brittle yeah yeah
sure now that we're all you know
30 years later and so like it's crazy
because like i mean oxel's racked up the
concussions man it's so tough for me to
watch that [ __ ] and like uh he's too
dead the new jackass movie is just it's
it's insanely [ __ ] good man it's
insanely good and and where where
jackass number two
tech has number two was good man
i recently just watched them all one
night again in any case what all i
really meant to say was that knoxville
and tremaine and spike are are like like
they're you know like people have like
they always want like uh
to make their dad proud and i'm no
exception i want my dad to be proud but
like that extends to those three guys
too like they're
them being proud of me like any praise
that they give me
is like in this world
there's like
very [ __ ] little that means more to
me than that because they're good
leaders that's exactly they know what to
do and if you can impress people that
you think are [ __ ] amazing
i mean what more can you ask for and and
i'm uh
i'm a [ __ ]
i'm a lot for those guys because their
their approval means so much to me like
i'm constantly seeking it and like just
barraging them with like
more [ __ ] like not like every new
youtube video like come on you know like
they gotta know about like and to be
fair i have been
really
hustling man like here's my new book i
just finished it you know like oh check
it out you know my warehouse where i
took on like uh i we we um
felt like we were like
selling so much stuff
particularly through like the the
charity fundraiser we were doing just
the volume of [ __ ] that we were shipping
out through our third party fulfillment
center
like it was just like dude we're making
so much money for them like [ __ ] it
we'll get our own warehouse and
so i got my own warehouse my own
warehouse staff [ __ ] and i do i fulfill
all my own merchandise
and just like
two days ago
like after i mailed the book to
knoxville and then with the the this
text thread with those guys and i'm like
remember my my fulfillment my
fulfillment center the warehouse
operation
i call that business
tight
box
[Laughter]
we smashed a [ __ ] hole in the wall
uh so that we wouldn't have to walk
outside the door all the way to the neck
because we rented the next warehouse
over too
oh you got going like professionally had
someone put a hole
oh you just smashed it okay yeah i
kicked that [ __ ]
i got my i know i asked
my business partner to try to handle it
with the one-inch punch
remember that [ __ ] yeah oh yeah i'm not
strong yeah
i threatened my kids with that all the
time and walk up to him
that [ __ ] was real
smack
i definitely bugged those guys a lot
with all of uh the various endeavors
that uh that i'm on and you know every
like little new piece of merch that i
develop and like i i barraged them with
you know like people are like uh what do
you call it fishing for a compliment
yeah yeah
i'm just straight fishing for praise
like yeah but it's all positive man
that's the best thing yeah i think
they're proud of me i think that like
when they get all my texts i think that
they're like okay yeah [ __ ] you all
right [ __ ] but good [ __ ] all
right way to go you [ __ ] douche they
help put you on though so it's them it's
like you're doing you're running with it
yeah you're still running with
right right but i think they're they're
they're genuinely proud for me and
they're like all right it's just so
evident that i'm like
like
some kind of like just needing
validation from them so desperately that
like there's like
there's no realm i can imagine where
they don't just see it as just desperate
and annoying but they're also really
proud because because of my tireless
[ __ ] hustle man
like in my new book i've got like uh one
of the big [ __ ] things that like the
in italics like the question
are you are you happy
like like i
i that [ __ ] question when people ask
me am i happy
it like
it took a long time for me to realize
it's just like
it just makes me [ __ ] uncomfortable
and i had to really think about and be
like i don't [ __ ] like it when people
ask me that question because
like the honest answer is no i'm not
[ __ ] happy like if somebody has to
ask you are you happy like for me you
hear that question and you contemplate
it for a second
and and i picture it's like well let me
like scan my body and how do i feel you
know like
i feel [ __ ] anxious i feel [ __ ]
twisted up and stressed like there's no
contentment that i can perceive i'm not
not like no i'm i'm i'm not happy i feel
i feel palpably uncomfortable you know
and i was like when people ask me like
are you happy i'm like hey
i find it offensive you know like
because because it's not okay to say no
i'm not happy you know and and like over
the years
the question just bothered me it just
bothered me and then finally i just like
really picked it apart and i i asked
myself like okay like what
i'm not happy like what's going on here
and i and i just think to myself okay
like the reality of my experience in
life is that like
and i think that maybe it's got
something to do with like uh with being
an alcoholic and like an addiction
because alcoholism and addiction have
nothing to [ __ ] do with drugs and
alcohol yeah the drugs and alcohol are a
symptom of the underlying addiction like
the underlying condition is one of just
general discomfort and disease you know
like we're restless irritable and
discontent you know that's like this
baseline my default setting
like as as a default
my feeling is
that like everything is not gonna be
[ __ ] okay everything's not gonna be
okay like whatever i have i'm gonna
[ __ ] lose it all like i'm gonna
[ __ ] lose it all like the whatever
the worst [ __ ] thing is gonna can
happen that's what's gonna happen and i
just that's my default setting my core
belief in any given moment is that
everything is not gonna be okay
and like while that's a super sad
and tragic reality to contemplate like
the fact of it is
that
that that
default setting
is it
it
manifests as just a [ __ ] fire under
my ass like i feel like my constant
feeling at any given moment is that
everything is not going to be okay and
my only natural reaction to that feeling
is
[ __ ] i've got a hustle
i gotta [ __ ] hurry up let's go and
let's [ __ ] get to work to try to make
it so everything will be i don't think
anybody's ever put it so perfect bro i i
feel what you're feeling a lot of the
time i've got and i gotta [ __ ]
i'm freaking the [ __ ] out if i don't get
off my ass right now and do some some
considerable work to to try to make it
so that everything will be okay and
that's like the engine that drives me
that's exactly
so it's like if i'm to ask myself okay
i'm not a comfortable person i'm a
[ __ ] super uncomfortable person like
i'm not a happy person i'm like
essentially very [ __ ] unhappy because
i'm so uncomfortable but would i have it
any other way would i want to be like
what's [ __ ] being happy what is that
like okay so so if i'm happy then that
means like i'm content i'm content i'm
satisfied i'm fulfilled i'm [ __ ] lazy
you're done i don't want to be [ __ ]
happy like if i if i had a choice
between being happy
like and or being the way i am
i straight up i'd choose the hustle 100
i'd choose the hustle man i'd like to
[ __ ] be more stoked but also i would
like
you
bro you said it so [ __ ] perfectly
it's it's it's the it's
i'm always smiling everybody i'm always
you know [ __ ] stressed out i am all
the time it's non-stop because i gotta
give her my [ __ ] family doesn't own
their houses i got to get them [ __ ]
house i got to buy this building i got
to do this we do all our you know what i
mean it's
it's the drive like you said it's the
fire it is
it is it's like who else is going to do
it they're going to do it better than i
am if i'm not [ __ ] here
and invariably
you know
i think i i think this i could say that
this is a a pretty universal truth that
anybody who has achieved like great
success
like
anybody who really worked to to to
achieve things and and was successful in
achieving those things
that i think i think universally all of
those people will say that they were
happier
before they accomplished anything before
they acquired anything before they had
like you know like anybody who has
earned a great deal of money i think
will say
that they were happier before they
earned any money they were happier when
they were dead broke because they still
had something to look forward to and a
goal
right and and and this was uh i know
that i was certainly happier you know
like i i had uh
that might be i don't know i had an
ability to live in the present that that
i've since lost and i think i've lost
that to
whatever measure of success i've been
able to achieve and and it this was
distilled into a saying that i heard
which is that
uh
a guy who has
[ __ ] nothing at all a completely poor
man
who has nothing
doesn't need to worry about
anything except for his next meal
but the guy who has everything has to
worry about his last meal not that he
like has to worry about but but but the
if you're focused on what's your next
[ __ ] meal then you're living in the
present yeah and once you have like
achieved some kind of success you've put
together some savings you've got you
know like
stuff you've had success
your next meal is covered and so you
become [ __ ]
bent out of shape over like your last
meal and that's such a much scarier
thing to spend your time contemplating
to you know 100 uh we had chong on here
tommy chong and he said i've i've talked
to him a few years ago and there's one
thing he said to me that makes me like
okay some you know when you're just
[ __ ] stressed like can i just shut
the lights off and just nobody's [ __ ]
talk to me right now he's like the only
way you can be truly happy is living in
the present because the past might be
the past you're looking back it's like i
wish we were still in those times the
past is full of regret and the future is
full of foreign or if the past was so
[ __ ] awesome and now you're like you
know what i cheated everything i do it's
all downhill from here yeah it's [ __ ]
it's like the atlantic list yeah what
what next uh michael phelps you want
another one good [ __ ] job
what's up guys special shout out to one
of our sponsors this is blue man you've
seen them on our show many times before
you guys always say i was damn full your
hair is always on point and that's
because i try to take care of it man
this is i have to be on camera this is a
big part of it a lot of you guys leave
in the comments who's your barber how do
you do your hair i get that all the time
believe it or not i used to cut my own
hair until recently and rosie would help
me just because we're in a pandemic and
we couldn't go anywhere but now i have a
barber i actually use stuff that makes
my hair healthy and guys we haven't done
an ad reef or blue man in a couple
months i still use this every single day
marty knows every single show i have it
in the bathroom this is what i use every
time so real quick before we even get
into it go to blueman.com that's
b-l-u-m-a-a-n.com
that is their website check out
everything they got there so this has
vitamins and minerals to keep your hair
strong and i actually have from
experience right here honestly i've
noticed a difference i noticed my hair
is thicker i noticed my hair stays
better with this actually it's the green
one but i noticed my hair does stay
better not everybody's hair is the same
i'm glad you know that right now not
everybody's hair is gonna part like this
all right but not everybody can grow an
afro you see what i'm saying so if
you're like me and you don't know how to
take care of your hair and you don't
want to be trial and error like me take
the hair quiz and the link for the hair
quiz is going to be in the description
and linked in the comments so answer
these few questions gonna ask you what
type of hair what your problems with it
what do you not like the most if this is
just questions that a hairstylist would
ask you so they know what to do for you
best so basically as soon as you're done
it's super easy guys it's like 30 second
hair quiz you answer a couple questions
and it asks for your email once you ask
for your email and you give it to them
they send you a 20 off discount
pretty easy you get help and 20 off or
you can just you know not take care of
your hair but for those of you that
actually care and you want to do
something about it and you want to make
sure you upkeep the way you look like i
said go to blueman.com
www.blueman
b-l-u-m-a-a-n.com or click the link in
description the link in the pinned
comments on the youtube channel that's
going to take you right to the hair quiz
like i said takes you 30 seconds you
give them your email 20 off as always
guys thank you so much for watching the
ad reads back to the episode
well
in most cases the olympic medalist like
that that like
because i i knew a bunch of uh of
olympic athletes and and olympic
hopefuls you know like when i was
dropping out of school at the university
of miami like i was those guys yeah like
the the university of miami was an
olympic factory no [ __ ] yeah dude big
time that that's like the number one
diving platform diving swimming
powerhouse of the ncaa and um the uh
the olympic pool i think that they've
actually like demolished it somehow i
don't know if it's still there but um
the olympic pool
had the mural
uh painted like when you win an ncaa
championship they paint your mural on
the right right they had uh greg laganas
he's like the most famous olympic diver
or his platform diaper
and in the olympics like he hid his head
on the platform during a dive like it
was something crazy but greg louganis
painted on the wall and at the time that
i had uh
you know
dropped out and i was kicked out of the
dorms and i was just straight living on
campus as a homeless person
okay i was
some night
i i'd like and i'm running around my
video camera i'm going to be a crazy
famous stunt still going through all
that well yeah i'm talking this is like
i dropped out of 93
94.95
that was when uh
when i met um the the diver that i
became bros of the dive team
and
they lived this one apartment in this
student athletics they had a you know
the student athletic apartment you know
the area whatever is the student
apartments for the the scholarship
athletes they had there was a it was a
two-bedroom apartment
both bedrooms had two dudes and there's
four people in the apartment one guy was
a random swimmer the other three guys in
the apartment were the number one the
number two and the number three
ncaa ranked 10 meter platform divers all
of which got their murals painted on
that wall next to greg louganis like
that very year [ __ ] great
and they're such a huge part of my story
because i'm like everybody's like oh
dude you're gonna be a [ __ ] stunt man
you're a [ __ ] you know losers and
that and like here i'm i was teaching
myself how to do backflips i was like
you know throwing myself off of like
rooftops and like you know all this
stuff breaking your phone
these guys specifically the number one
in the country and and his name is brian
gillully he was also um
he set a record that will probably never
be broken he won 10 consecutive junior
national titles
from like the age of eight to
like uh no uh
no olympic hopeful no uh platform diver
in the u.s under the age of 18 could be
an eight-year-old the next year none of
them could beat a nine-year-old
he won junior nationals in some respect
on one of the boards every year for ten
straight years from the age of eight
years old he was the most unbelievable
prodigy at eight years old and then when
he was 18 and he went to his very first
senior nationals like i have the footage
still i just digitized it the other day
[ __ ] before the scores were up you
know on his last night brian glearly 18
years old is the national diving
champion before he even scores because
with that dive that back three and a
half [ __ ] he ripped it so clean and
um it was it was that same guy brian
gillully
when i was homeless and he was letting
me live on his [ __ ] floor sleep on
his floor and uh and and i i taught
myself backflips by like climbing up on
top of [ __ ] i like before i off a car
off a table or something because to get
the rotation i needed to come up from
higher
and he
like took me under his wing and and
stood there and spotted me like like as
a spotter and and cleaned it up and like
taught me how to like swing my arms into
it so that i could do a back flip like
standing still on flat ground to get
that full rotation without i got trained
by him you know
and uh and and like within
what like within about a year
i wouldn't say within a year of brian
literally like cleaning up my back flip
my standing back tuck
i taught myself
like fire breathing and i figured out
that if i poured rubbing alcohol on my
bare hand i could light it
and the rubbing alcohol would burn like
thinly enough that it wouldn't really
like burn my hand at least not at first
so i would have time so i could fill my
mouth with with it pour it on my hand
then light my hand on fire and it
wouldn't burn my hand so bad and it
would be it would it wouldn't go out so
easy my whole hands on fire and so i
could swing my arms into a standing
backflip with my hand on fire and use as
i tuck upside down in the air use my
flaming hand as a fire breathing torch
so that i'm
simultaneously
blowing a fireball it was a
simultaneous fire breathing backflip and
i'm guaranteed the first person in the
history of humankind to do a
simultaneous fire breathing backflip and
and i know a few people have done it
uh you know since seeing me do real tv
can eat a dick for that 500 bro right
it was the same trick on the roof of the
three straight building i poured the
alcohol and then i used my hand as a
torch and and uh front flip fireball off
the roof so i'm gonna get in your brain
real quick you're like i can do a
backflip i can light it on fire what if
i did it all the [ __ ] same time and
that was just your party trick
for sure well i mean here's the thing
the first time that i ever it's crazy
got on stage like legitimately in front
of hundreds of people it was 700 people
it was in florida at the the stuart
opera house and and what had happened
was this was in in 1996.
and it was it was
um i was homeless i was like living out
of my car i was couch surfing um
i uh and living out of a car that i just
got in my second dui in which had
expired tags which i was continuing to
drive around
i i was in such a low point that i
actually wanted to carbon monoxide
myself to death
and simply could not afford to fill the
gas tank
like i was it was not i was not i was
not winning oh my god that's a that's a
bumper sticker
i was not on a winning streak and i
heard like on the radio like the big
radio station was uh doing a uh a freak
of nature contest it was like a talent
show kind of a deal and i'm like oh dude
yeah i'm like i'm a [ __ ] badass stunt
man i'm [ __ ] stevo you know but part
of me thought like you know the the
harder i'm trying and the like the the
the crazier footage i'm getting like
maybe i'm gonna be like somebody you
know and if i'm beginning to become
somebody do i really want my name to be
steve-o like it's kind of goofy it's
kind of like is anyone going to take me
seriously am i am i am i am i [ __ ]
myself by calling myself that or should
i call myself by by my real name steve
glover oh my god and i was like having
that [ __ ] little debate in my head
and then um i call the radio station i
said i said i'm what's your what's your
then what's your talent what's your uh
what's your act
i said i'm stevo the alcoholic gymnast
i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna get on i'm
gonna i'm gonna [ __ ] come out i'm
gonna get on stage i'm gonna [ __ ]
shotgun beers faster than you could even
believe because like in all my exploits
all my things i've ever done in the
world uh the one thing i think i really
was world class at was shotgunning beers
okay i think i'd like if they had an
olympic
[ __ ] sport i'm right with you i kind
of i might have got a medal and i'm
shocked on the mirrors because i i
actually breathed it i had nothing to
stick with
and i was it's just like that [ __ ]
fast yeah it was it was gnarly and so i
sent my shotgun beers faster than
anybody
like you could even possibly imagine
you're gonna know that i drank the whole
[ __ ] thing because i want to throw
the can on the stage you're gonna hear
it [ __ ] land empty
and i'm gonna i'm gonna shotgun so many
beers that i am like visit like like
undeniably i'm gonna get undeniably
drunk before the eyes of the audience
and then i'm gonna proceed to do
acrobatics and like brian glooly also
taught me to like to just place my hands
on the ground
and slowly
press up
into a handstand like not like kick up
you know but just put my hands down and
press up slowly until i'm up and and
hold it still where like if i'm falling
if i'm gonna fall forward i just you
know put a little pressure on my
fingertips or my heels and like
you know like just balance like legs
press up to a handstand hold it
perfectly still
and um
and then my last little thing was and
then when i'm done i'm gonna like
like blow a fireball at the time i used
to use rubbing alcohol which is just
terrible [ __ ] to pour in your mouth and
and it's super dangerous too because
whatever you spit it on stays on fire
and i've lost a lot of skin over the
years get like with accidents from fire
breathing it's not
but uh but hey but it's a little bit of
a saving grace that whatever it lands on
stays on fire
but i didn't i didn't have it figured
out at that time so
what's two things that are important as
they they wove me and i came into the um
a little audition for them and i showed
my fast deck of shock and i did some
some uh acrobatics and they were like
dude we [ __ ] love it you're funny
yeah you're on the show they loved it so
much that they they brought me out at
the beginning
like every couple acts i came back out
like i was woven through the show so i
came out in a shotgun two beers through
the entertainment get another act and
then i get another act then i come back
he's gonna come out shotgun two more you
know i think i did like shotgun like
nine beers like uh on the first show you
know by spacing out weaving me through
and then like i started doing tricks at
the end and like the crowd just [ __ ]
kind of ate it up they're like dude i'm
[ __ ]
you know like he's gonna fight and i do
it again
and i'm like kind of because they're
spacing it out like i'm getting more
drunk and it's like
he's going to come out drink more
stevo the alcoholic gymnast coming out
to [ __ ] chug more and the crowd kind
of got behind it and like
i i'm on standing on that stage nervous
as hell because like in front of 700
people but they're like
they're [ __ ] like kind of chanting
from steve
steve oh they're screaming stevo
and and like
in that moment hearing that i'm like
like my little debate my debate ended
because i'm like if i if if i had said
if i had said i'm steve glover the
alcoholic gymnast not one [ __ ] person
is gonna scream steve
steve glover you know but steve oh
steelo steve like
like it was just and that was how i even
got the [ __ ] name in the first place
was from drunk [ __ ] yelling at keg
parties at the university of miami while
i'm doing whatever dumb [ __ ] i'm doing
it was like inherently
[ __ ] infinitely screamable like
you know
and so i made the decision on that stage
that night like
that's
the take because i heard them screaming
chanting
like so and i committed to it then 1996
i'd i'd made my decision i'd been stevo
already for a few years but then i was
like that's it i'm steve i committed and
hindsight is the best [ __ ] decision i
ever made yes because
if you look at the guys from jackass and
like who got like uh like real name
recognition
with all due respect and love for my
bros i gotta say that every single one
of them who went with the name that is
on their driver's license
[ __ ] themselves yeah because like
anybody used their name from their
driver's license didn't get name
recognition out of it
who do you remember you remember bam
that's not his name johnny knoxville no
that's not his name it's a great man
we man yeah you know like yeah
dave england it's like you don't want to
say someone's real name that's
interesting when you're right
and i mean i i never would have even
seen it coming if anything i thought i
was like taking a crazy risk but in
hindsight to have a name that's easy to
remember that's kind of goofy like
totally you're gonna remember it because
it's steve oh it's not gonna just name
that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] dumb to call
yourself steve oh you know like it's
like we man you know like bam it just
rolls up so it's involved
it makes people remember
your name you know and so that was
like something that like a really was a
valuable thing and then when i got to
the end of the performance and i go to
do my fire breathing
like
i had a i clicked a lighter i brought a
just a regular bic lighter and
i [ __ ]
i
[ __ ] blew out
the lighter and and in front of 700
people
it was this
like the that it was just this
anti-climactic super disappointing like
it didn't light it was just like a mist
of liquid and there's it's ah but
[ __ ] and i'm like i was mortified i
was [ __ ] [ __ ]
and by the way
okay all right i'm gonna [ __ ] do it
again i think it was actually um
because because i did this two nights in
a row
you know they had they they did the show
chance i think it was on the the the
next night but whatever who cares if it
was or if it wasn't but i did it again
and uh and this time when i did it i was
more mindful to to not try to blow out
the lighter you know i had never blown
out the lighter before i was able to do
it you know
but uh what happened was it was
unintentional i was still doing the with
the lighter but when i went to to blow
it i did ignite the fireball
except
i ignited the fireball and and didn't
even realize it but in in spitting it i
had spit the rubbing alcohol all over my
hand so the fireball ignited but now
i've spit the rubbing alcohol onto my
hand so like it's on there and then it
stayed on fire and so like i'm like i'm
like
styling out taking like yeah taking
about and all of a sudden i realized oh
[ __ ] my hands on fire you know like and
i'm like
you know and like you know like it's
totally after the fact i realized [ __ ]
it's on fire and i can't really [ __ ]
shake it out and i was like man
it took me like a number of weeks
to put it together but i was
so traumatized by the lighter being
blown out and the the disappointing
failure to light the fireball it [ __ ]
traumatized me
and like and and it was just it was
fascinating that
that when my hand had been on fire and i
didn't realize it
it took a beat you know it took a couple
seconds for me to even realize that it
was on fire because it burned so thin it
doesn't really hurt at first
and then i thought
i just came together it's like [ __ ] what
if i never have to worry about blowing
out the lighter ever again and i know
that like kiss they would like you you
know they'd use a big torch but i didn't
want to use a torch
yeah
so i was like what if i never have to
work what if what if the solutions i
never have to worry about
about blowing out the lighter again is
if i just start out by pouring it on my
hand and then light it and use my hand
as the torch and i did that and that was
like that in and of itself
made like everybody seen fireball i was
like okay i'm sort of fire but because
i'm pouring on my bare skin and lighting
on fire that just gave me like an extra
like edginess it was like wow dude
that's gnarlier
yeah and and all of this happened in
like right when i was just just [ __ ]
got the backflip locked and then i
thought oh [ __ ]
what if i [ __ ]
do that and then swing into a backflip
and and it all just happened in a short
ass period of time
question
that experience if you're going on stage
is that that hook you because you said
i'm an attention [ __ ] and you got the
[ __ ] crowd attention i mean dude it's
uh
okay
is it there's something big in that
question
did it hook me like because you were
going full force already but like i
i i told you first thing out of the gate
that that i i identify as an attention
[ __ ]
and what's crazy about that
is that
and there was in sixth grade i had uh
when i wrote my first book
um you know we were pulling together all
kinds of uh you know stuff for
you know
like research stuff stuff and we pulled
out all my report cards when i was a kid
my sixth grade report my sister saved
everything i do too i'm a hoarder too
but my sixth grade report card my
homeroom teacher whose name was alice
iacquesa had this like this thing that
she wrote and i remember like
being like
30
[ __ ] 35 or something reading it hurt
man it was it hurt
she wasn't trying to be like me and or
her but it was just so accurate she said
on this comment
that
steve is so desperate for the approval
and affection of his peers
but
the things he does
to
try to get the approval and affection of
his peers
like
bring about the opposite results
so i was and it was just so true and it
was so piercing it just like pierced my
heart it was like i was so desperate for
that validation and i i was just
overwhelming and like
just
graded on i was just like it was just
too much you know like i wanted to be
liked so badly and i tried so hard and i
tried so hard in a way that actually
made people not like me and so i had
this like tortured shoot yourself in the
foot and that's so
so that's why it hurts like to to hurt
to read that comment it hurts
to to like really like
to to ponder that reality because like
what
as an attention [ __ ] like i care so
much about other people's opinions of me
such that like i'm really at the mercy
of them
and like where like i put myself out to
get attention like really what i want is
validation i want approval i want
affection and to put myself out there
like i'm so terrified
of getting that opposite result so like
i don't know if you can relate to this
but i was the kid in school
who whenever
i had to get up in front of the class
and give um like a a
presentation to the class
you know like when the kids some kids
got up in front of the class and you
could hear their voice shaking stage
fright you know they could hear their
like they're not like their and it's
like it's almost like stuttering because
when you when you most don't want that
to happen it's when it happens for sure
like you're like oh please don't let my
voice be shaking where they can tell i'm
trembling because i'm so nervous afraid
but because you're you know that of
course it does yeah and so like i mean
like i i i look at that you know that
beings like
i was that was the attention like you
would think that i would being an
attention [ __ ] being like a natural
like showman like having it in my blood
to like be a performer that i would like
revel in getting up in front of the
class that that would be like me and in
my happy place but no dude i was
trembling in fear you could hear my
voice shaking because like i wanted to
be in i wanted to have the attention of
the whole class but i was so afraid
of disapproval i was so afraid of
rejection like that that like it's just
terrifying and so that's like this the
scary [ __ ] reality the torture of
existence like
and for more and more people now with
social media but like you put yourself
out there you want so much like the
likes the affection but then like you
put yourself out there with the negative
comments that just [ __ ] up your day
and so the answer to your question was
was i hooked
like was i addicted to like to the being
in front of the crowd
i'm terrified of it dude [ __ ]
terrible like that's my life is that i'm
i'm an attention [ __ ] and i have to put
myself out there to try to get
validation
but i live gripped by fear
of uh of rejection or uh like being
denounced or [ __ ] so it was drugs and
alcohol was using that i think so i
passed that i think so
break the ice
and not care so much but yo you're
stupid it's all right they love it and
this whole like this whole thing of like
i'm like i'm terrified of like of not
getting uh approval and affection and
validation it's just super real and that
manifests this crazy anxiety and sure
that's gonna drive drinking and alcohol
and then there's the i'm going to lose
everything like you know i gotta hustle
and i'm never comfortable you know and
um
that's like uh
i think that meditation helps me a lot
i'm on a crazy meditation streak like
coming up on two years where i do the
kind of i do the kind of mantra based
meditation that you do twice a day like
20 minutes each time so like i've
averaged over 40 minutes of meditating
every single day for like
670 days
wow i've spent like coming up on 500
hours meditating and less than sitting
by yourself which is good though it's
it's uh my brain doesn't stop figuring
out what happened that's basically
is to like
is to just take that time to just
[ __ ] unplug from all of that
anxiety and and discomfort and would you
would you attribute that to like getting
helping you get sober
um
like a disciplined meditation practice
came much later i got sober in 2008
and uh i learned to meditate in 2013 for
the first time kind of dabbled in it and
fell off and then i i took another
meditation course in 2019 and have been
religious with it
that's great it's like you were so
rewarded for so long from the world for
being crazy and drunk and wild like to
go get clean
had to be so difficult like you're
giving up i mean yeah like yeah then the
motivation needed to be um
like
in pitiful and incomprehensible
demoralization you know like that like
for for to do the work of recovery
most alcoholics most addicts need to be
quote pretty badly mangled
you know
because it's not like
like like the the program of recovery
for for people you know the 12 steps and
all of that like
it's things that that like our basic
instincts like every fiber or being cry
out against doing
against like okay now i have to be
rigorously honest you know i have to
like take account of
of
like all of the wrongdoing that i've
done and be honest and upfront about it
and acknowledge it and then i got to go
and set about making those wrongs right
you know like
[ __ ] that scary and then you know like
i gotta
be with
thinking about uh
you know
a higher power and prayer and meditation
you know like that's super that was the
easy part for me because i had like had
so many like crazy hallucinations which
i like to this day
fully considered like
legit spiritual experiences the whole
world is real oh dude 100 i think like i
said i think meth heads are walking out
there and they're on the other plane you
think they're crazy they're just seeing
what you can because they're brilliant
i'm stoked that you say that because i
feel strongly the same way and what it
is
is that like
we i mean there's
i think that like like scientifically
recognized there's 11 dimensions you
know like we're in the third one yeah
and so it's like we've got this like
very limited like uh physical matter you
know like 3d plane
and that's our box that's our
compartment you know and like
i believe strongly that if we ingest
enough
like
drugs slash and or booze
because like say it's called psychosis
people become possessed on drugs man
it's called psychosis where like you
start hallucinating hearing voices and
what's interesting you mentioned meth
but like
all kinds of different chemicals like
like arrive at the same place
you know psychosis you can have alcohol
psychosis i think
different than psychedelic yes or no i
mean it did like
i i mean when the psychosis is psychosis
psychosis i feel i think of like manic
like what um
when someone's so cause i've had a lot
of friends they're gone but i've had a
lot of friends go so far off
that you look at him and go i feel that
you believe that you see other people in
the room and i can't see it and i think
you think it's so real that it might be
[ __ ] real right here's here's what i
believe is that when we when we
ingest enough of these
substances what we what we do
kind of inadvertently is to like erode
the compartments which contain us in
this
3d in this level in reality
and
like what's important about that
is that
like they're like everything is energy
like consciousness is energy i mean
everything is consciousness and
consciousness is energy and like energy
vibrates at different frequencies you
know you've got like
higher frequency shape you've got lower
frequency [ __ ] and like to say high
frequency or low frequencies kind of the
same thing as saying angels and demons
good evil you know i'm good and evil
angels and demons and and
like when
when you like take all these substances
all the meth you know all the coke like
all that you know whatever it is and
like you erode the compartments that
keep us contained in our 3d experience
by eroding those those barriers you're
opening yourself up to
like other
dimensional
energies
and
like you're opening yourself up
there's no there's no protection you're
just like opening yourself up to all low
frequency like
you know like low free that's why you
see like meth people completely like on
some crazy like
like negative because it's like they're
letting in
like low
low frequency [ __ ] you know other like
it's like they're now like my experience
with psychosis there was like
angels and demons you know like straight
up and i had like some voices telling me
that they were really worried about me
and like you know like like we don't you
know
we need you to take care of yourself and
then i had other
like voices telling me i'm worthless and
i got to kill myself and like all this
but like zero question in my mind that
[ __ ] was completely real you know
it was completely [ __ ] real that's my
mom got off drugs she said she saw a
[ __ ] demon in the mirror and it was
her and she's like that's it i'm [ __ ]
possessed i'm done she was on the bank i
was a kid i've heard stories like this
my dad says the same and everybody who's
had these experiences referred to
these uh
like the spiritual entities as the
committee
i came up with the word the committee
because you're like you you find
yourself asking these voices in your
head like how does it work you know and
like the the the consensus understanding
that i got
was that like that like spiritual
entities from like other dimensions are
absolutely [ __ ] fascinated with our
experience you know like it's so it's
like uh it's like a grand experiment
that um that they're really [ __ ]
glued to you know they're really glued
to but the rules of the universe
are that they cannot interfere with
their free will
they can't step in and and manipulate
the outcome of [ __ ] you know so they
just have to kind of stand back and like
check it out you know tv show at this
point yeah and and and when uh
i think those rules get get bent a
little bit when when we [ __ ] around with
drugs to the point that like we open
ourselves up to all that yeah but uh
have you done dmt or the i think i got
out before dmt was a thing
[Laughter]
thank god i got out before fentanyl oh
[ __ ] that's in my mind there's such a
distinction between fentanyl and all
these like wow i mean yeah i watch all
the youtube videos and like they're all
pretty clear that like
fentanyl is uh
it's it's an opiate similar to heroin
but 50 times stronger than heroin it's a
0.1 for [ __ ] od man people are dying
off nothing
like why the [ __ ] are they cutting
fentanyl in with cocaine like that's so
it's so stupid killing all your [ __ ]
customers off first off i mean it's
crazy i mean i i'm just thinking from uh
it doesn't make sense it doesn't make
sense why would you want to
it's a long thing going on
i'm sorry i'm so grateful that i [ __ ]
got out man that i got
badly
mangled enough to have to like adopt
like okay i gotta do this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that nobody was there was there anything
that helped you really get through it
and turn into who you are now all these
years later i mean like what helped me
get through it was just like you know
getting enough clarity allowing the fog
to clear enough to see like what i had
become you know like i can't it was like
a vicious cycle of like i would just
like act the way i acted and i'd be so
embarrassed and i would just like get
loaded again and then like then that
would make me do more [ __ ] that like i i
became a [ __ ]
it's pretty awful person is it hard for
you to watch those oh yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] it's it's awful if you check out
this for that first book i remember
writing that first book and like
unlike the the documentary that they did
about me it was called demise and rise
this uh mtv documentary about my
downward spiral
which was gnarly it was graphic as [ __ ]
yeah the apartment [ __ ]
that [ __ ] documentary was nothing
compared to like
in in the book because you've got like a
book you can explain so much more you
know you can go into so much greater
detail do you do your own audibles for
the books um you know like the [ __ ]
publisher
like screwed up my they scheduled it
while i was on tours and so i ended up
like being able to do two chapters and
then some voice
when i was like finishing up that first
book i was just like
[ __ ] dude i'm gnarly dude like not even
like
not even like like i'm gnarly like rad
like i'm just
do you guys deal with me [ __ ]
you know like and not even like i can't
believe i'm alive which which is legit
it's legit true i can't believe i'm
alive but it's just like dude
like not even like in a good sense and
not even like
just for like from an objective point of
view i was just like dude i am [ __ ]
gnarly you know like
those are intense yeah did you still
have your dad looking over your [ __ ] at
that point so you didn't i did i did and
and at that point when things got really
ugly like
um
i i was able to dictate the terms of our
relationship you know like
dad was uh
you know like where the stunts initially
like drove us apart
and then starting with that real tv deal
the stunts actually served to bring us
together you know they and and they've
developed this crazy bond between us
and we had that bond and dad was very
much in the loop with like the the
business side of my career like copied
on all the emails with the entertainment
lawyers and the business managers and
dad was like you know we developed a
very codependent relationship where dad
was in charge of like my finance
world you know like i never would never
look at like anything from the
accountant or the business manager and
like dad would be organizing everything
for taxes that's what he does
it's perfect it's awesome but it's also
like he just [ __ ] was handing me fish
for years and years and like i didn't
know how to [ __ ] work a fishing pole
so like i was like depending on
depending upon him in a scary way and
then like as far as like with my money
like what what what we did was um like
it was basically like half of the money
that i allotted for investment
went to my dad and the other half of it
went to like like a legit like new york
stockbroker guy who did investments and
it was like set up to be like a fun
like competition between them to see who
could like generate more
what a [ __ ] team
yeah
like they would be like kind of it would
be like a playful bet you know like oh
who made who who turned who made my
money grow more you know
and i i paid zero [ __ ] attention to
any of it you know and so dad dad was
involved in that and when things got
really dark like
i like
dad was pretty good at just like not
allowing himself to realize how bad [ __ ]
was you know he kind of had like that
denial going on um
but but he figured it out and when he
did like if he ever tried to bring it up
it was just like anything to do with my
lifestyle my health you know drugs now
call i was just like nope we're not
going there we're not having no interest
you know i dictated the terms i'm not
going to talk about that this
conversation's over if that's where you
want to take it
and and i was able to dictate those
terms because i wasn't like dependent on
you know i had like you know
i didn't i didn't depend on dad and for
for money you know
like i could ostensibly
cut ties with my dad and still like keep
doing my thing so he really had nothing
he could do about that and um
you know and then and then dude i'm so i
get sober in march of 2008
and then [ __ ] september of 2008 the
[ __ ] the
financial collapse
and like here's how [ __ ] scary that
was for me
like
i'm
i've been operating on
like the assumption the core belief that
i would not
make it to the age of 30. from like the
age of eight just because you're so wild
there's something about that default
setting where i'm just there's i'm just
defective there's something [ __ ]
wrong with me just letting you cry
and then like you know i don't know like
what like
maybe that and and and like
the way that the way that like i was
just in the grips of drugs and alcohol
and i didn't feel like i could ever
stop you know i'm sorry i was just gonna
drink and drug myself to death even if
that wasn't the case like long from back
when i was in school i could not bring
myself to go to class i could not keep a
job i could not do anything unless
i i was passionate about the idea of
doing it
like
in the absence of enthusiasm i was
crippled
to perform basic
like functions
you know like
to perform basic tasks for any human
being i was [ __ ] crippled and and i
maintained to this day
that
like as as
as valuable as intelligence is you know
as
as instrumental as discipline is
no they they aren't [ __ ] compared to
enthusiasm you know enthusiasm is the
driver
of success you know like i've never
heard anybody put it like that i've had
people
ask me like over the years
you know ever since the beginning like
like how do you do this how do you do
that like i want to be a stunt man or
like whatever you know like you know i
want to get into that like i don't give
a [ __ ] what
anybody i want
to fill in the blank i don't care what
it is you want it doesn't matter what
you want this has been my advice to
everybody for forever it doesn't matter
what you want what what matters is how
bad you want it
you know like it like it and and uh
remember my dad that i made a
documentary about
my the early years leading up to my my
career beginning
um and i made that in like 2004
we shot everything in 2003 so 2003 we
had an interview with my dad and my dad
said
when steve puts his mind to it
there's nothing that he can't accomplish
the problem is
that's a fairly narrow slice of the plot
of the pie
that makes sense like what what what i
what i apply myself to what i put my
mind to what i'm enthusiastic to do has
always been such a very narrow
piece of like
of you know what it takes to what it
takes to navigate the world that i i
grew up
like
not wrong that like when it came to
performing basic tasks required for
survival in
the landscape of our society
i was [ __ ] crippled
i was not equipped with the basic
survival skills to make to take care of
myself to to succeed on any level and so
i i expected that i would fail miserably
in life i expected that i would die
young and as i grew older and and even
when i achieved like some kind of
recognition and success then all of a
sudden it just transferred like the you
know my
addiction to drugs and alcohol got suits
and i was like oh that's going to kill
me you know like
there was just never a view
that i that i had of my future which
which
allowed for me to live to see the age of
30.
and then when i got sober in march of
2008 i was 33
and now and and up to that point i never
[ __ ] paid any attention i wasn't
saving for anything like i went through
i didn't even have a [ __ ] atm card
for like the first like
three years after jackass came out you
know like
like i just didn't i didn't care
you know like i i
i mean
maybe it was like two years
i don't even remember where i did like i
had some shady [ __ ]
like rave promoter guy acting as my
manager and he like
like i would do all this old tour like
the don't try as a home tour and a lot
of it i'd get paid in cash
so like i didn't have to go to atm you
know i didn't have to go to any team i
had like you know
plenty of cash from uh from what i was
earning with my my personal appearances
on tour
and i just [ __ ] did drugs and i
wasn't saving for anything and i didn't
think i was going to live and just like
wow you know there's no planning there
was no saving there was no paying
attention to anything and i knew that i
was doing pretty well you know i had the
vague sense that like uh
you know
sometime i think in 2002 or 2003
like i cracked uh like two million
dollars that i was worth or something
like coming from my business no wait
that means i'm a multi-millionaire yeah
yeah because it's like one million but
now it's two yeah
you know i remember thinking that was a
pretty big deal but that was like that i
didn't pay attention i didn't care and i
thought everything's gonna be fine
i thought i was gonna be dead so it
wouldn't matter [ __ ] and then i get
sober
in march of 2008 and all of a sudden now
it's like oh okay like
now i'm
i'm like
now i'm turning my enthusiasm to my
commitment you know to like
to to not
being the [ __ ] douchebag that i've
finally recognized that i had become
that's all i cared about
and
and now in in in doing what
i will move whatever [ __ ] mountain
has to be moved i will do whatever
anybody suggests if i can just not be
that [ __ ] guy who i'm so humiliated
and ashamed of having been i don't want
to be that guy anymore and so now like
i'm i'm that's all i cared about and now
i'm like to do that now i'm like
taking care of myself now i'm like and
now i'm like and most people would most
people would
would meet like the realization or the
suggestion
that they're not going to die soon and
be like
glad
most people would think like oh that's
good i don't have to worry about that
for me it was the complete [ __ ]
opposite because i'm like
okay so i thought i was going to be dead
like in no time now i'm faced with the
most terrifying prospect that
i might only be halfway through my life
like now like i could i could be staring
down the barrel of i've gotta
[ __ ] figure out
what to do with like
what maybe 50 more numbers of people
would live until i'm 80 you know and at
the time i was 33
you're like so all those scares
[ __ ] no and especially because
here's the really crazy part right when
it occurs to me that i might actually
have to figure out how to feed myself
for the next 50 years when mind you the
nature of my career was precarious at
best
on top that i had burned every bridge in
my career you know as far as i was
concerned my earnings potential had run
its course you know like i i had you
know i i didn't know i like if i'm gonna
stay sober i can't be a [ __ ]
egomaniac attention [ __ ] anymore so
like i don't even know if i can pursue a
career even if one's in the cards you
know i like i don't even know if if i if
if i can
if i if i'm done earning money and now
i'm faced with maybe i'm going to live
for 50 more years
and i don't know how i'm going to
survive i don't know
how many and on top of that come
september
at the [ __ ] financial crisis hit
everything
my dad and the stock broker had me
all in the [ __ ] stock market and the
stock market got [ __ ] chopped like
more than in half i lost more than half
of my savings i wasn't even a
millionaire anymore
you know i wasn't even a millionaire
anymore i don't know didn't know that i
could [ __ ] earn any more money and
now i'm gonna [ __ ] live for a long
time like what the [ __ ] what a
combination man yeah it wasn't [ __ ]
that's stressful honestly
yeah i mean and in one sense it was like
super terrifying and in another sense it
was like i was back to all i got to
worry about my next meal
you know like there was something about
that early
like early recovery where like you know
i lived in a [ __ ] halfway house until
i had been sober for two full years you
know like i had a [ __ ] roommate and
he snored and so when he snored i knew i
could jack off and it would be good
you know
yeah the sweet sound of snoring i called
it
oh my god so you live in the halfway
house for two years after that
i stayed in the halfway house until i
had two years of sobriety yeah that's
amazing we were shooting jackass 3d
and i was like asking for special
permission to like
like come back afterwards were they so
happy they had to be like
i don't think anybody cared one way or
the other you know like
like alcohol like the disease of
alcoholism and drug addiction is like
super not discriminate you know for sure
that doesn't [ __ ] care if you're
making a big shot movie or you know or
if you're living in a dumpster
doesn't matter
um
real quick i have a question for you
you got a whole list of questions i
didn't let you get to one of them and
you explained so much
yeah you already went to so much i've
been just
crossing them off so
for all the crazy [ __ ] you've done
you're afraid of bungee jumping in
heights yeah
i [ __ ] hate it how did you do the
[ __ ] dog [ __ ] porta potty
then i i did the dog [ __ ] i was the dog
[ __ ] porn-a-potty guy because i've got
that
fear of uh bungee jumping they made you
do this [ __ ]
because that just means that i'm gonna
get the biggest reaction i'm gonna get
okay this reaction you know yeah okay i
get it um
like it like there was an episode
of wild boys which we found um i think
in 2003 maybe 2004.
um yeah i think it was 2003. and and uh
like they took they're like okay
we had a research department that would
just like you know research different
places if we go to this like how many
what do they have to offer that we can
film and then we'd choose where we would
go based on the places that had the most
like you know content that we could
shoot and in costa rica they had like
this huge bridge with this bungee
jumping operation
and like that's pretty run in the middle
and everybody goes bungee jumping but
they made it funny because they got our
prop master
to build like
[ __ ] like icarus wings you know like
actually with feathers and glue them all
in and like you know it was like maybe
built with like crutches or something so
you hold the crutch and you've got these
wings and it was gonna be like i'm gonna
[ __ ] fly you know i'm gonna jump off
the thing and i'm gonna i'm gonna try my
ass off to flap the wings
and that was gonna make it like a funny
bit
so we go to the uh
like we're getting ready before we even
go there i said to him i told him i said
dude it's like
straight up man like i'm always trying
to be a badass i'm i'm
like
you
you could take
like
it's like
the the cast of road rules or or uh
the real world or like or any of their
moms
will be less afraid
of bungee jumping than i will be you
know
and and i i kind of figured that out by
like from my like
jumping off of like rooftops i started
out on just like the first balcony up
where i'm like only like 10 feet and i
was like into the pool and then i'm
going to climb onto the second
then column of the third you know like
and then the roof like so it worked up
gradually you know
and uh i worked up gradual and i made it
like i always wanted to like
create the perception that i was super
gnarly and that i was risking death you
know and like make but but i always had
my own approach
where i was like pretty calculated
and like really put effort into like you
know preparing and like working working
my way up
yeah i mean i think people are real
[ __ ] and i went through life for years
looking
at everything as for like for its
potential to jump off of it like
everything like everything is just like
oh can i kind of jump up so i would
evaluate everything and around me and
look at it and like
through years of doing that
you know i i just
i was so close to the idea and so in the
practice of evaluating
like
my potential for jumping off things
that i reached a point where
like if i'm there's
no part of me
could look off of a 200 foot bridge
and and i don't care what you tied to me
like i'm this is a problem that i have
placed myself
just too intimately
like involved with i'm just too
intimately involved in evaluating
jumping off of things for me to
see anything doable about jumping off me
of a 200 foot bridge like i know more
than anybody else not to jump off of a
200 foot bridge so i don't give a [ __ ]
what you tied to me i am way i'm
programmed to not do that of course
maybe
and so then and they were like oh [ __ ]
are we just gonna go there they're
thinking whatever yeah and and and and
it was one of my temper tantrums like
i'm not [ __ ] doing it dude i'm not
[ __ ] do it i said i don't care what
any of you guys say i know that you're
very persuasive i know that like this is
your deal and and it's not gonna work
i'm not [ __ ] jumping is there a lot
of times you had to like stand up and
say no to bits not too many times and
and the the
they can have they're never fortunate to
doing it we're all attention orders we
want the footage you know like they
always say if you don't do don't do it
it's great you know you don't get the
footage
i cannot like i will i physically cannot
i physically cannot
look off a 200 foot bridge and jump
there's no way i can do it like i'm i'm
not i'm not doing it i can't even i
don't even have the choice to do it i
cannot do it brain tells you don't i
just so i just go into the [ __ ] van
you know and i'm just like okay dude we
can we can leave now because it's not
going to happen
and then that one producer comes over
and he goes okay
i've got
you don't have to jump i'm not going to
try to make you jump but but but i've
got
five
costa rican locals who are willing to
pick you up and throw you they oh
and i was like i was like i was like
okay well in that case
i don't have to jump
you know like don't have to i don't know
because i couldn't bring myself to jump
that's all it took they're just gonna
pick me up and throw me and there's
nothing i could do i don't have to do
anything because i let a mafia toss me
and i just like my whole body was just
[ __ ] fists
and i hate it dude i'm [ __ ] like i'm
working on a video where i'm like
you know you would not you won't believe
what my biggest fear is like you know
like roller coasters
[ __ ]
maybe with the roller coasters like
again i'm too close to the problem like
i know like what's a natural amount of
time to be weightless like free falling
like uh i'm not okay with extending that
you know
like i know i'm not okay with not being
uh
you know like i don't know man i feel
you 100
making a video about like confronting
all this and i did like bring myself to
jump off of uh
the tallest commercial bungee jump
operation in the world which is in south
africa just went hard as hard as you
could it was indeed like for the closure
for my tour and i should be promoting
this too because i'm going on uh tour
soon it's my bucket list tour where i've
been doing stand-up comedy for
you know 11 years
but over the course of time it's it's
with each special that i've filmed it's
it's become
like
the first one was just straight stand up
and i did some stunts on stage guilty as
charged that was guilty as charged was
really awesome i loved it really dude it
was like a play i i appreciate that a
lot i feel like like i would i would
cringe to watch it because oh it's great
well thanks man and then i had my second
one when i was putting together that
second show i was like oh man i'm
telling all these stories
you know these these craziest stories
and like there's like
almost for all of it like there's
footage to back up other stories and i
was like what if i put out a comedy
special where you see me telling the
stand up but i edit in the footage of
the stories i'm telling like actually
illustrating it i'm like dude multimedia
stand up comedy this is [ __ ] insane
and uh and it worked so well and that
was my second comedy special gnarly
and then when i came to put together my
third year when you taped yourself yeah
okay okay then when i put together my
third show which is the one i'm doing
now
like
i was self-conscious you know i was i
don't want to say i'm self-conscious of
the fact that my gnarly
that that whole tour that that whole
show
was was like living in the past you know
i was telling my craziest old stories
but i felt myself turning into
the kind of guy who won't shut up about
what he used to be able to bench press
when he was in high school
you know
like living in the past felt distinctly
depressing to me
and i was like okay like i don't want to
live in the past but i love the
multimedia thing so for my next show and
this is the show that i'm touring with
now called the bucket list
i thought
let me [ __ ] do like all new [ __ ] and
and make uh the act about that and
incorporate the footage into the act and
i was like i knew exactly what
to do i knew exactly what to [ __ ] do
because like
i just right away i called it the bucket
list so right now i'm on the bucket list
tour when does that start i mean it's
been it's been going it's been resumed
since uh august
oh you've been back on
back on since august and so much sicker
now dude
and um i've got shows coming up in new
orleans atlanta chattanooga tennessee
um denver um i saw fresno on that list
too
yeah like it's booked out until february
so by all means check out stevo.com and
uh see my website or my tour dates but
um
like the the so the bucket list i just
knew right away because i've had like
these these ideas
that i've had forever and like zero
intention of doing them and one of them
involves skydiving
and here i'm like [ __ ] terrified of
roller coasters and bungee jumping dude
i never wanted to go skydiving not for
the [ __ ] one second and the way that
i kind of got out of it the way that i
like like you know did it well yeah this
is the thing dude like going back like
20 years skydiving whenever it came up i
was like oh not dude [ __ ] i'm not
[ __ ] scared i mean that's not an
early dude that's not [ __ ] everybody
does [ __ ] skydiving you know there's
a way out of it i'm not that's my way
out of it that's my way out of it that's
cool so to to further solidify my way
out of it i would say everybody goes
skydiving [ __ ]
no way dude that's lame i said if i ever
go skydiving
i like because the first time you do it
you've got to have a guy strapped to
your back i said i'm going to be [ __ ]
butt ass naked with the dude strapped to
my back and i'm just gonna be [ __ ]
straight furiously jacking off
and i'm gonna [ __ ]
and i'm gonna [ __ ] jack off and i'm
gonna [ __ ] blow a load but like
i'm gonna make it i'm gonna time it so
that like i'm
i'm actually blowing a load falling out
of the airplane that's my that's like i
called the idea skyjacking
wow and i [ __ ] did it
dude i have 10 videos like that play
instrument like after every bit in the
show i screen the footage of like the
and every bit is so over the top like
it's so it's outrageous to tell the
story of it that it's like funny for
stand up and then after every bit now
you're going to see the footage that i
just explained me jacking off guys right
look
dude you see a lot of my [ __ ] dude you
want like uh you got the the vasectomy
olympics because not only did they do
the vasectomy where they cut the vas
deferens but now i'm going to [ __ ]
go horseback riding bareback [ __ ]
galloping with my balls bouncing up and
down on the horse you go so hard with
the [ __ ] vasectomy olympics
it's absolutely
insane i got i got like uh the
anesthesia bike ride with general
anesthesia drugs coming into an iv while
i'm on while i'm holding us on a bicycle
so you're starting to lose it's so
[ __ ]
it's it's so [ __ ] illegal
i
got a medical professionals doing
straight illegal ass [ __ ]
i got a [ __ ] doctor
who he puts a four inch needle into my
spine and injects a drug into my spine
which just [ __ ] paralyzes me
from the waist down it actually
paralyzed me like from the waist up too
which wasn't supposed to happen but that
happened while i was [ __ ] sprinting
with my hands handcuffed behind my back
what just shut you off that's the level
of the bucket list let's say these are
ultimate that sounds like
and it's it's like the footage is is
just
so x-rated it's so [ __ ] illegal it's
so gnarly and like and and it it's
exclusive to the tour do you have l.a
shows oh yeah i love them have any la
shows
um dude i just i just did brea
they've got you on the road doing
theaters through november through
february literally damn near every day
not every day first second third fourth
there's a lot so many shows he's all
over the place
and i love that london but the homeboy
said the theater because dude i was
grinding and comedy clubs i understand
for 11 years oh yeah and i just [ __ ]
graduated to theaters congrats man
that's huge
a theater comic is a whole nother
[ __ ] moment and and it was
we started to film the fourth jackass
movie
we were like we got one week into it
during that week that first week of
principle of photography i'm on the set
and i get the call from my agent and
he's like congratulations dude you're
selling out your comedy club dates like
so far in advance of the comedy club it
just does not make sense to entertain
any more offers from comedy clubs so
congratulations dude you're a theater
yeah man congrats i i [ __ ] hate i
hang up that call and i'm like i'm on
the set of jackass forever
i just graduated from theaters i'm like
[ __ ] dude i've been
dude i'm [ __ ] going into a heyday and
then the following mondays
[ __ ] coronavirus shut down the
[ __ ] movie it's shut down the tour
and uh and and i i was like i was pretty
butthurt about that but like but thank
god that happened because i was straight
touring myself to death and back in the
comedy club days like it was like every
gig man
doing the show like five times four or
five or six times you know twice a night
like i mean dude it's gnarly thursday
friday saturday yeah same show like that
yeah you know the comedy club yeah he's
on the comedy scene it's gnarly man and
[ __ ] and and i was
here
that seemed like gripped my fear about
like [ __ ] dude i'm going to be alive for
another 50 years like
it's like waking up for school monday
like i gotta do [ __ ] tomorrow
why didn't i hustle and and uh make all
the money i could make doing stand-up
but that's not a bad that sense of
desperation is what you're supposed to
do it's a driving for sure
but
but thank god the the coronavirus came
along to force me to take a break from
touring because otherwise i never would
have given myself did you come back with
a whole new set though dude i i never
would have given myself a break
and and did i come back with a whole new
set not a whole new set but uh but i i
threw out some some bits and they added
some some some bits like i came i came
back but they [ __ ] dramatically
improved
the bucket list with a bunch more
footage
and um
and more importantly
i never would have given myself a break
from touring coronavirus forced me to
take a break from touring and during
that break like i started my own podcast
you know the the wild ride podcast and
that's been [ __ ] it's been huge man
like there's so much to be said
for
for being a creative person like a
creator
and not
living in a groundhog's day of
redundantly performing the same [ __ ]
over and over whether that means like
redundantly going to the airport to go
on a plane to go to the [ __ ] radio
station to go to the show to go [ __ ]
repeat the whole thing
like it's it's monotony and and i
maintain that any
comic
on the comedy circuit who tells you that
that they're a passion they love
the [ __ ] groundhog's day life of a
touring comedy dogs this is a line from
my new book like if any comic who says
they love the groundhog's day lifestyle
of the comedy circuit is either lying or
considerably more mentally ill than i am
that makes sense
because it's such a it's you know and i
know it's a shitty [ __ ] thing to say
for all the thousands of comics there
are slugging away [ __ ] grinding away
wishing they could be a headliner and
just performing comedy tirelessly for no
money
and i get it that like to [ __ ] about
the the lifestyle of the the headliner
traveling [ __ ] sucks though
every weekend
the show is one percent of that [ __ ]
job yeah that's not like and then when
and then when the dude when the [ __ ]
with the table talk and the
like
i lose my [ __ ] yeah i bet like
you know
if somebody's [ __ ] being loud and
disruptive talking at the table and and
ruining it for everyone else like wait a
second dude you are
you're serving as an obstacle between me
and the dissemination of my art and you
that is not okay you know
it's funny man i could see you being
hell for a [ __ ] heckler
what the [ __ ] dude
like all of those experience like uh
pile up and pile up and then you've just
got the [ __ ] straw that broke the
camera's back and you'll just [ __ ]
lose this [ __ ] yeah yeah he's going to
guide his wife
and listen here man i take what i'm
doing if you're really [ __ ] seriously
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you got to be a dick for you to call
somebody an [ __ ] though i mean that
person's got to be a [ __ ] beat you
get drunk [ __ ] our comedy shows oh
bro
my crowd drinks so much yeah
the sober guy like i'm constantly that's
the word
yeah dude i always hear like oh man like
you know we broke a record selling booze
at the stevo show
not for me
yeah that's awesome dude uh before we
get out of here um last thing you said
an hour and a half we did two and a half
did we really i went closer to it
i pride myself on being a pretty good
podcast guest well dude the stories just
float man and things we want to hear um
and dude like anybody i love to do this
after i feel like you know i recorded a
podcast with people who was where it was
like a good one i think this really was
a good podcast um
and i say this a lot to the listeners of
my own podcast you know like if you're
hearing me say this now you know in this
case like close to two and a half hours
you've hung in there and like
and and that's such a big deal you know
like we know from looking at our
analytics like the retention [ __ ]
falls off a cliff you know like you've
got like a a rather
small percentage
this guy stays 90
yeah dude that's insane and congrats to
you for that and they're gonna they
they're gonna love this man i think i
think that i think we provided a
compelling i don't think we had a lot of
love
a compelling listen
you know
throughout and to the people who did
stick around this long for starters i'd
like to say thank you oh yeah and for
being in the live chat we do a live chat
for every show and they stay the whole
[ __ ] time yeah i mean dude it's it's
it's like that's kind of like commitment
and like being the attention [ __ ] that
i am
like like
like having
having kept your attention for two and a
half hours like to everybody like like
that that that is the sustenance of my
soul but now it's really with your it's
with your thoughts it's not just you're
crazy sure it's you that's that and and
that's the other thing too that it's
it's uh it's something that i'm i'm
super grateful for
like because i think that the general
like perception of steve oh this [ __ ]
thoughtless reckless [ __ ] crazy
maniac is probably nuts he's probably
addictive you know like
and and
i think that it's
surprising to most people to learn that
i'm considerably more thoughtful
than than than my my actions my behavior
would suggest you know it's
controversial
right and so for everybody who's who's
who's
so generously given me their attention
for the last two and a half hours like
now
like it it's it's
it's fulfilling you know and meaningful
like to to have
communicated to them like more like who
i really am you know like i think that
there's uh
a level of intimacy
in in uh in a relationship that i have
with these listeners now you know and so
i just can't say enough
like the extent to which i'm grateful
for for this opportunity to to
communicate to these people and and from
what you tell me you've got
some uh a substantial audience they
i [ __ ] love you guys i know these
people's names are in the chat every
single week every video every post every
dm every everything and i said it before
too like that you know i i
i care about communicating and
communicating in a way that's compelling
and you know
that's really about it but but like even
maybe inspiring because i've been such a
[ __ ]
train wreck you know like such a train
wreck and and uh on the leaderboard of
celebrity death pool you know
like
that you know
for me to have pulled myself out of like
really the jaws of death oh you know and
like and and
and managed to survive a but but also to
reinvent myself and to evolve exactly
into uh you know someone with like like
i've learned from my life experiences
and stuff and and so i don't know i just
think that um
and um
two days ago i delivered that [ __ ]
new book i talked to knoxville about it
today that shit's gonna come out not
until
um september oh my sorry not sorry
spring i was looking for another 22.
spring of 2022 which is crazy because
jackass forever will come out in
february
and then who knows this will come out
maybe the next month like march or big
[ __ ] man yeah so god i want this to be a
[ __ ] number one new york times
bestseller oh yeah well we'll [ __ ]
leave the links to everything so yeah
sorry if uh
if
if you can do this the people listening
and thank you and by the way thank you
and now let me ask first for something
it's like i'm not it's not lost to me
that that's douchey but i believe it's
it's i believe in what what i'm saying
about my first book
that for for you guys to pick up a copy
signed by hand and i'm careful to make
my signature it's actually a dick
like the oh my god
like uh yeah dude you got to see my dick
so yeah check it out but go to stevo.com
and get a hand signed copy of
professional idiot it's the juiciest
[ __ ]
book of sex drugs and rock and roll and
just
absolute mayhem
it's not gonna it's it's
dave england told me the other day i was
at his house dave england from jackass
he's like man because i told him i was
working on my boat in my new book and he
goes dude your first book he says uh
you know i i thought [ __ ] man you know
it's stevo like i i [ __ ] feel
obligated i gotta [ __ ] like fight
through it because he's my bro i just
gotta like i have to do it he said i was
not
at all prepared for
it to be impossible to put down whoa
like that was like
high praise i was like dude from your
friends man yeah he's like dude i'm
being completely honest i expected it to
be [ __ ] work and a hassle to get
through which i had to do because you're
my bro mm-hmm and i couldn't put it down
it was so [ __ ] the best review you
can get seriously for the first time
tommy lee from motley crue on the cover
he says this is the perfect book for
people who hate reading
nice it's like tmz level of reading
you're a molly crew [ __ ] fan dude i
know that yeah and that's epic for tommy
a good job so in any case man like um
if for nothing else just to have it like
uh get that book but
but to get that book knowing that the
next one's coming oh yeah and the next
one is like
i i won't say the main title but it's
it's it's uh
what i've learned from a lifetime of
terrible decisions
and um
and like it and it's uh
i i let that [ __ ] [ __ ] rip dude like
the [ __ ] that uh
the [ __ ]
knox said like leave the bukkakee out of
the first book i was like dude if you
thought the [ __ ] in the first book
was [ __ ]
edgy
[Laughter]
if you're still listening
[ __ ]
shoot a tweet with me like with my
handle in it so that i see it saying i
made it to the end
of the dope as usual podcast and thank
you guys again for not smoking out the
room of course man i i i know people
don't smoke
you know i wouldn't shut up because i
didn't finish my coffee
you're all right you're all right but
the thing i wanted to say is i've seen
in many things you've said the only
thing i want to do with my life is be a
crazy famous stuntman and everybody
[ __ ] love it
and congratulations man that's exactly
that's exactly what it is yeah it's
gnarly
[ __ ] awesome man yeah dude thanks
brother thank you so much you guys
thank you for sitting through this i
[ __ ] love you guys for being in the
chat still thank you guys steve oh thank
you so much for being here wait they're
in the chat now no no i just say it
because i know i'm in the chat with them
while they watch it every week or dude
that's crazy it's it's it's a long time
so that means that you i'm talking to
every single person while they're and
you're playing it back
yeah well we we edit it drop it monday
and youtube does that premiere so we're
in the live chat while it while it drops
till it's over wow it's funny i should
do that you should you know people would
lose their [ __ ] mind if you didn't
here's the thing and for practical
purposes like this is the most
professional [ __ ] thing if you do
stand up
and you're a podcaster then you gotta
know
i think that the overwhelming majority
of stand-ups
cannot
[ __ ]
bear
to to watch video of them performing
stand up surprise is the most agonizing
excruciatingly uncomfortable thing
to
watch video of your own stand-up
performance
it's just
utterly demoralizing and and just it
makes you question everything that
you're about you're like i'm not [ __ ]
i edit myself so i'm like come on man
right the [ __ ] wrong with you as i'm
editing myself and that's when that's
where i was at i would film the
occasional show when i first started
doing stand-up but if i tried to watch
it man it was [ __ ] hard and i really
resisted everything about watching this
yeah and and uh
it turns out that to watch in front of
your stand-up is the most
productive the most like
it's like a football player watching
games exactly it's footage it's way
bigger and better than that i think i
think even your bodybuilder
and where i where i got incredibly lucky
was
that
i had that that little [ __ ] light
bulb go off and i thought what if i
edited my footage into my stand-up and
as soon as i came up with that idea
while i was putting together that second
show
i was so jazzed about it i absolutely
could not [ __ ] wait and in short
order i started recording my my
performances
loading them up into the computer myself
and then dropping the footage into the
timeline and syncing it all up and i
found two things number one
uh it worked like it [ __ ] worked i'm
telling the most outrageous [ __ ]
implausible and
like impossible to believe stories
and
now i'm dropping in footage that the
backstage
verifies it so like that's crazy because
the fact that the stories are true and
then there's proof that they're true and
it just makes the jokes even funnier
like it just it was like bringing these
two worlds i was in the stand-up world
at that point and i was in the video and
i brought my world my world came
together in this powerful [ __ ]
like
and
by
the fact that it worked meant that i had
to keep doing it and i kept the timeline
but but i and and then watching the
footage of me performing the stand-up
made me cringe it was agonizing it was
like [ __ ] ah
and and uh
and i simply addressed the [ __ ]
things
that made me cringe like there was this
there's this common
insecurity and stand up where you'll do
like a little [ __ ] fake laugh at your
own joke and like
it's almost like
i guess some people if it works but like
i would do that and that that was my
biggest thing on guilty of charge that i
would like put a little fake laugh
behind like my own joke and again and
again yeah and and like
ah you know like it's just that's just
straight insecurity it's like trying to
tell yourself that it's funny where like
if it's funny it's funny you know like i
don't have to [ __ ] laugh at my own
joke and like that's like just a one
example of like the many [ __ ] the
myriad things which i would by studying
it
able to
address the thing and then i would be
like i'd be like okay cool man i'm gonna
go [ __ ] work on this and i'm gonna go
[ __ ] film that show and now i'm just
gonna delete out the like all the
interstitial clips are on a higher
[ __ ] uh you know level
i'm going to delete out the [ __ ] the
performance foot and then i'm going to
bring in the new one and i'm going to
move it with the tinker and move it all
around and line it up and i'm going to
study that again you know and in
studying it like dude exponential
[ __ ] growth as a performer and stand
up and and i say that because when you
talked about
your in the live chat
i just did i
recorded my first podcast with tony hawk
and and i remember awesome i i came out
of that i thought oh my god dude that
was our first podcast and if any
podcasts we do after that are that good
i'm gonna [ __ ] freak out like
and uh
and i told the guy like i i'm an
independent i'm not with the network but
i've got a guy who sells my ads and i
was just like dude you gotta listen to
this [ __ ] podcast before we put it up
gotta listen to this podcast how dope is
it and he's like
why don't
why don't we get together and uh and
play it back you know together you know
now he's already watched now he's going
to want to if he wants to watch it again
and and he's like
and i was like uh all right like this is
dope right and he's like we'll watch it
and he's like
here he and and the point that he made
when we watched it back and by the way
it was a very different experience from
when i was recording it with tony hawk
thinking man this is going so great and
then all of a sudden i'm watching it
back and i'm like
oh
you know like
it went like and i was like [ __ ]
and
and
my podcast guy made the point he said
here you've got
this [ __ ] icon
you've got tony hawk
the [ __ ]
most famous skateboarder ever to live
and like
you sucked all the oxygen out of the van
and [ __ ] like didn't let him
[ __ ]
that's my biggest thing i had to
critique myself like am i talking over
[ __ ] right now
this is the one i went do not talk over
that's just trying to like just listen
like i i tried you
you did great and and and here i sucked
all the oxygen out of this room and like
you guys let me do it and i think that
like if if if i was
communicating poorly or if it was like
you know then then you would probably be
able to like and interject and kind of
reel it back in and keep it on track but
i don't think you had to do that
so i think we we did that very well it's
very different from being a podcast
guest where it's okay for me to just do
what i'm doing
compared to being a podcast host
and and and it's been a real struggle
for me
to to grow as the podcast host and not
suck like suck all the oxygen out and
then [ __ ] not let people talk talk
over them interrupt them i'm glad you
said that man i've been struggling with
that [ __ ] for about five months now just
trying here's the same [ __ ] thing
as
with the
stand up it was it was a virtue of
necessity that i had to
study the footage in order to
edit in
the interstitial shots to illustrate the
footage and that forced me to do what i
hated doing the most which was play back
and study my own stand up in in doing
that i
progressed at an exponentially faster
rate and just improved as a performer
and and i did play back that tony hawk
episode and and you know like got super
motivated to grow as a host
but
frankly and i'm admitting this like i
haven't had the stomach
to
play back
podcasts
i know that i i just know that
but here's like this is the the i think
this is the if i the podcast will
perform better if i'm in a live chat on
a premiere yeah and it's just and by the
virtue of being in the live chat on the
premiere once again i will be now
forcing myself
to watch it back and study it and and
address the the concerns with live
feedback with you with live feed because
i'm literally talking to people hey man
you're talking about yeah yeah dude
that's like a goosebump [ __ ] it's
good though i'm gonna probably like
reference
that like that's that's where because
i'm i'm on podcast number i think today
we recorded number 82. oh no [ __ ] how
did you do every week yeah we do it once
a week and i started when the pandemic
shut down when does it drop uh thursdays
every thursday it's thursday at eight in
the morning but now it's gonna have to
move
to a later time i'll tell you what i
work with a lot of big comics and
podcasters and stuff i have in my career
i always try to explain this model to
them because it's so important to why
his fans are so dedicated long term and
why it keeps going up like his run is 10
years long and just getting started
exactly because of his relationship with
his fans because he communicates with
him he talks to him he goes live he does
premieres he's got david cho going live
tomorrow oh [ __ ] bro come on that's epic
are you kidding me be in that live
[ __ ] chat do it for five minutes dude
some of the [ __ ] guests that i had on
my podcast are
they're epic
i've seen
come on man i've seen
you had [ __ ] chong on recently be
real is here next week actually oh [ __ ]
should i have said that yeah anyway yeah
he's on your next week um yeah your
guests are just stacking there dude
he's [ __ ] cool man
like he he's one of these
like
iconic [ __ ] like legend status people
who is just
doesn't think he's better than you you
know like
that that's [ __ ] that's a big deal
man but yeah yeah i think you guys just
got me to step up my game because
because it's it's like a little black
cloud that follows me around where i'm
ashamed of it like man i would don't
embrace that [ __ ] i would i would be i
would be a better podcast host i would
be a better performer if i was studying
my performances but it makes me
uncomfortable the idea of doing that so
i'm going to avoid doing that and now
i'm just by not doing that i'm going to
be uncomfortable about the fact that i'm
not doing that and that's just going to
like add to my anxiety you read the war
of art by steven pressfield no oh my god
please please listen or read it
he describes everything that he
describes what you're talking about as
resistance and that everybody faces
resistance especially the artist and all
the different ways it manifests and the
whole book is about conquering your own
resistance which is like you've brought
up a lot in this
yeah that sounds great man and i just
got done with the book man like i'm
i'm really [ __ ] making a book is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ton of work oh yeah
i mean and now
and it's the same co-author that i did
the new book as i did the first book
with which i'm just stoked on
and uh you know again it's been 10 years
in between books been more it's more
like 11.
and uh in the in those 11 years
homeboy's written book after book after
book
and like on this one i was i was because
dude like i'm i'm a [ __ ] psycho once
i'm into it like i'm like
like strikes through highlight it read
it's gone and then what's what's going
in is like all caps highlighted green
it's going in and then just a note from
me to to the author is highlighted
orange that you just like to
to keep them up and like these [ __ ]
chapters are so spreaded out out of
drink this is so gnarly and i'm like to
the writer on the phone i'm like
for all the books you've written like
does anybody
like who's been a subject of one of your
books has anybody been even close to as
meticulous as as i've been in
in the revision process and he's like
yeah no one no one near it's good though
man yeah and because dude you got to
imagine too like a bunch i want to know
there's no way of really knowing but i
would love to know out of like
out of in the the the world of of memoir
like celebrity memoirs
like written with with co-writers you
know or ghostwriters whatever like
who
who
like
just
didn't even [ __ ] put anywhere totally
you know like most
like he doesn't get everything right you
know but like he's he's just like okay
now i'm gonna just try and crawl on your
head and like in some cases i'm just
gonna
[ __ ] throw it at the wall perfect and
like uh and
some of the [ __ ] he didn't get right at
all and i rewrote it
and some of the [ __ ] [ __ ] blew my
mind
some of this [ __ ] [ __ ] blew my mind
excited man it'd be sick if you filmed
like if you do the audible version i did
this for my book and then you film
yourself reading reading it so now you
have a video version also it's just
it's just it's just cool video versions
just have a camera right there while
you're doing putting out your clips now
now you got some clips to put on your
clips channel
how i made my book yeah audio very
really interesting idea man i [ __ ]
love it yeah it's good man um all right
dude so just shoot the tweet guys
[ __ ] uh tweeted if you made it
we're like we're over we're deep yeah
we're deep down what's your longest
podcast uh four songs with his mom
scheduled i'm going to [ __ ] change
the schedule i'm gonna it's like an hour
of my time to be in a live chat it's
used to the performance of the fun your
fans are gonna like yeah and you know
every person's gonna go to sleep
rocket ship on
the the performance of the podcast and
it's monetized too we could talk about
that more but it's yeah i'll give you
some tips for you uh off here there's
there's so much you could do with just
being there and not even that every
person's gonna go to sleep going steve
will [ __ ] comment it back to me in
the live chat that's the real thing and
that's the thing that makes everybody's
[ __ ] day because when i was a kid if
i would have said some [ __ ] like fart
says or [ __ ] to me
here's me here's what a [ __ ] neurotic
[ __ ] psycho i am i'm gonna be like
you're [ __ ] these [ __ ] people are too
busy [ __ ] typing they're not [ __ ]
hearing where's me
you're not listening because you're
typing with all the [ __ ] multitasking
going on over here they're not [ __ ]
getting it
the [ __ ] up they will man
everybody stop typing and just listening
yeah it's like when i'm uh like like
when people are responding to my tweets
while i'm tweeting during the ufc fights
i'm like dude what are you [ __ ] not
watching the fights yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm not banging up like so i can just
keep watching
yeah dude it's crazy man yeah you guys
are the best thank you so much man we
really appreciate it guys thank you so
much dope as usual podcast have a dope
ass day
all right damn that was way long
[ __ ] yeah
good
[Music]
[ __ ] perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]